hello
super trooper nation i am your grand
master of the super trooper army ethan
klein with me my beautiful co-host
uh ela cline my two co-hosts shredder
and uh alfredo
afraid about it um today we have the
legendary casey neistat with us the uh
grand master vlogger innovator
and uh entrepreneur entrepreneur
workshop organizer he's got a crazy
workshop that i think people really like
professional runner runner the guy runs
a lot he's force gump essentially but
not [ __ ]
you guys who are familiar with to drop
the arbonne you cannot say that word
why not heela it's the
it's the r word it's the r word it's the
r word yeah
let's see before before we bring kcm he
is awaiting backstage on the gatsby
which is really exciting but before we
bring him in
i want to announce that the new
collection has dropped today at
teddyfresh.com
lots of good stuff there's a huge
collection guys it's so funny here take
a look at the screen i'm going to blast
through this really fast eli you talk
about it
zepa putty color block can it hug tie
dye
that tie dye um color black hoodie and
new colors
what whoa whoa hold on let me find out
we got new beanie colors
this is probably one of the most
exciting um release
this year we saved all the good stuff
for fall you know new windbreaker and
two colorways
you've got the coach's jacket for the
first time when you dip up hoodie for
the first time
yep uh here's one of the new color
blocks yeah that's a t-shirt
dude look at that [ __ ] give me a break
get out of here with that [ __ ] uh
t-shirt there's so much there's so many
here's the other new color block
look at those dude fall colors baby
that's how we got to do it
there's another zip up i gotta go even
faster color block zip up
uh zip up the bar that's the new color
block this is i like to call this one
the barbie
the barbie color this is the need a hug
crew wow give me a break
uh there's so many items keep going
another colorway oh my god need a hug
okay oh oh there's so many okay this is
the polo that i'm wearing i love this
shirt
look at the colors on that polo it's
[ __ ] oh god
uh look at all the products dude okay
we're done this is such an
awful beginning to this episode
well we gotta we gotta always be uh
always be chem always be plugging always
be plugging well with that being said
now that i've dropped the r
bomb f-bomb and had the worst intro
possible to our
uh podcast here with casey let's bring
in casey
hopefully he can make this a little bit
better so without further ado
uh i i welcome mr casey
neistat to the show uh casey
that's your cue baby
oh hit him with the oh you see dan
that's what i was afraid was gonna
happen dan
you
i can leave
dan good to see you guys good to be here
to see you welcome to the h3 podcast
i really appreciate the whole entrance
situation
well it's supposed to be taped down more
i apologize because it just came up like
a
flap at a deli but it's supposed to
explode damn that's what i was afraid of
you got to tape the sides
you know i'm not are you i don't want to
throw anybody under the bus or anything
but stuff
throw anyone under the gatsby maybe it's
time for dandas
no offense dan yeah you did a great job
but besides that
casey is here i've got somebody here to
make some changes
i've got somebody who's good at taping i
can say are you telling me that you're
drinking is this hot cocoa
or pumpkin something it's definitely not
pumpkin it's gotten
it's this is a soy milk latte
with some chocolate or what no i don't
do dairy
you don't do any dairy are you lactose
intolerant mm-hmm
you just don't [ __ ] with there i don't
[ __ ] with you are you vegan weird to
suck on cow tit
i'm i am vegan you are yeah i didn't
know that
yeah i believe it since when but you're
you're so jacked i'm like one of those
jacked vegan dudes
that's cool okay first of all okay i
didn't think i didn't thank our sponsors
butcher block no butcher box
oh my god butcher block no no box
oh it says block in my document we gotta
retake this episode oh my god
butcher block box right dan
butcher box box butcher box
and bomb bass sock company teddy fresh
of course
now you're one of these jacked vegans
but you're you run a lot
when you're jacked so are you doing
push-ups and sit-ups and all that [ __ ]
are you doing weights like why is this
part of the plug
are we still are we still doing we're
not plugged in
don't kill the dogs i've got eyes on
both of them okay first shredder
right behind you okay all right dan is
slowly backing the gaspi out of the
office such a mess
you know just thinking out loud here
yeah if the picture of the guest was
printed on maybe a thinner painting i
know that's
what it was before you perforate that
paper we've done
all of those that is exactly what we did
last night dan is rolling
literally shut the doors
that's exactly what we did last time i
don't know why these guys show up with a
canvas printout
not taped on the bottom i'm teasing it's
also terrifying
for the viewers at home your gatsby has
no breaks
and between the thresholds of the door
where i have to have momentum to break
through my canvas
picture there's like 72 inches tops
before you're at cameras and five points
yeah so this is a high
risk maneuver but you know what that's
the mobility
spirit that's the spirit when you get a
mobility scooter you'd like you drive
through an escalator you
have driven that escalator do you want
to see it i can't show you
but yeah no i don't know what that
sounds for was it an accident or was it
somebody doing a loop no it's hilarious
oh okay okay but he does die nope
nope he does he i believe you yeah but
that's just like as he goes
yeah well anyway he got he's he misses
the elevator
and he's like he keeps trying he keeps
ramming it
when it's clearly left and then he just
kind of like does appear and then it
opens and he disappeared no he didn't
open he
[ __ ] forced his way through he
literally died yeah good
hardcore metal dude that is so metal
yeah i'll show it to you off the air
because i don't think i could show
people dying yeah that's heavy
also where are we talking so do you see
sit-ups and push-ups and how why are you
so jacked
well um actually i've
broke my collarbone like a month ago so
i've been a month of nothing but
stagnation just kind of sitting around
eating stuff
waiting to get healed really how did
that happen
um i was on like a one of my motorized
one of my many motorized vehicles and
had a little bit of a goof
and landed on the old collarbone
interesting side motorcycle
no no it was like a it's like a one
wheel
one wheel it's like a thing one wheels
are amazing i highly recommend it for
anybody but motorized yeah i've seen
those yeah and pay attention i wasn't
wearing pads nor was i paying attention
and it like went into a pothole kind of
thing and just
oh no so you were on like a boosted
board one wheel yeah it's like a
what looks like a balance board you
cannot qualify enough for a disability
mobility
you know if you want to try one it
should be on your um
i should be permanently on the gas here
i'm going to show you guys just for
dramatic purposes i'll show you an x-ray
of what my shoulder looks like because
i'm expecting some real
a really strong response to this photo
because it is
rather dramatic um you were going fast
presumably i i was going too fast to run
out you know like when you're going
really fast if you like fall off you can
just run it out i was going too fast
my god you tried to run it out and you
ate i ate i didn't try to run it out it
was just like
i was trying to okay so that's looking
at a human shoulder right there
and then cool right sick
[ __ ] awesome that's the that's the
human shoulder right there and then
that's a that's a oh wow that's a
serious break yeah that's right can you
see that can you see that
yeah yeah it contrasts a little yeah
there's a break
it's a break that's a broken collarbone
looks like that's not that's what it
looks right now
yeah wow kind of [ __ ] up how do you
treat do you just wait
yeah wait okay well if you want to get
into the the
nuts and bolts of it it can be screwed
back together
but you got your sternum here
which protects your heart and then you
got your actual shoulder which has all
these little parts in it to keep it
working
this collarbone's sort of a fuse so
trauma here trauma here breaks this
are you fact checking right now yes okay
so trauma here or trauma here
breaks this so if you have a lot of
metal there and you're active like i
am and you take a big fall either that
metal is just gonna wreck your
collarbone or you're gonna break
something far worse
so you just sort of let it let it be oh
yeah really so it's going to be all
deformed you can leave the door
that's okay and are you able i know you
just had a baby too
relatively really sweet right yeah all
right are you able to hold
i can hold her the only thing that's
tough is like when my older kid comes
running at me streaming pick me up
wow that's really uh that's a big uh
injury for you
yeah it happens not to me that doesn't
happen i never broke a bone in my life
ethan you gotta you gotta just ride more
electric
vehicles the beauty of the gatsby is
that
other people's bones break not yours i'm
not sure anybody's going to get hurt on
the gas that thing feels pretty outfit
for safety unless you go no
i'm the elevator door i'm fine the
people you hit other people
i see what you're saying i got to stop
cursing i said today
yeah we said no cursing and look at me
i'm talking f-bombs i open i open with a
r bomb do you think that's okay
no it's not okay it's never okay because
i opened like hard on with that r bomb
yeah you know
talking about kids you guys have it
coming up is how you deal with your
children when they swear
oh it's really easy when like a little
kid just yells out like
a swear word you just say don't say that
but when they use it
perfectly
[Music]
i was with my daughter at like the
grocery store and we're trying to pay
and they have one registrar and there's
a million people and they have like the
self check up and nobody's there to help
them all the lights are blinking
and we're just trying to get out of
there because we just bought our food we
want to go home and she looked at me and
she goes this place is a [ __ ] show
wow and all i can say to her all i can
say here is you're absolutely right
really
badass you know because am i supposed to
criticize that as perfect usage
that's that is a do you have a policy
do you like curse in front of her or do
you not curse strictly
try not to curse in front of your kids
yeah
but more importantly is you try to teach
them when it's appropriate when it's not
appropriate
owen the older kid is very good with
that when he was little
and because we told him that when it
sounds really bad when kids say and he
understood that he internalized that but
francine's she's not down with that
i got my words and i know when they need
to be used
her son doesn't understand words yet
yeah there will come a time in the near
future where
i will be faced with something i know
existential
issues yeah but but i really am trying
to stop cursing
and from here on out you will not hear
not even one [ __ ]
did you i appreciate that although the
way you just said that you should have
removed the context and it would have
you guys listen to remember when howard
stern went from fm
to yeah i listen we listen nowadays
it's the greatest show but it's always
been the greatest show but when he went
from not being allowed to swear to
swearing
at first it was not it was doing a great
disservice to his show
really it was just like because
everybody could swear everybody was
swearing
and then i remember when howard put the
kibosh on it
it was like guys no more swearing no
more swearing because if you use it too
much it loses its
it does it's thanks no i agree you need
that restriction to be correct i love um
jerry seinfeld's approach he thinks that
it's basically like the easy way if you
can do the same
without swearing it's better yeah i'm a
big um
world history buff and the f word was
used
so much in world war one that if
officers really wanted to get the
attention of the troops they would issue
a command without
saying [ __ ] in it because that's when
that would be taken seriously because
the f word was just
a part of every sentence really and
world war one world war one 1914 1918
yeah very serious
so let me let me dig in okay let's do it
i want you know i did not
use the reddit uh thread for questions
for casey
that's mostly out of fear that's good
there's there's that yeah there's
nothing bad
i want to ask you you know i'm going to
go out of order here
did we ever have beef i feel like i
don't know that we ever had a direct
beef we ever had beef i mean i made some
videos that you guys didn't that you
didn't like you were pretty critical of
them
but when people criticize the work and
not you
i think it takes a really weak person to
take that personally especially because
like
you kind of had a lot of points you know
like when i did something that was
which ones are we talking about because
i i like the the
hillary video like i thought you and
phil had really smart
critical responses to that and i think
both you guys were right
i was going to ask in retrospect looking
back on the hillary vid
do you still stand behind that video
especially everything
that's transpired since then you know
well i think
one i think you you asked me that like
right after i made it
and you gave me like really you ethan
gave me like really
smart feedback yeah you because you were
like you know i voted for hillary
clinton that's true
yeah and so i i mean yeah like i really
think that the way
i and this is true for that video
politics and just sort of everything in
general it's like
that's why the hot take is so dangerous
right when you let emotions lead instead
of letting
rational thought lead so i mean if i'm
gonna get really into the weeds on that
when i look at a video like that like
what was my goal
my goal was to sort of share my
perspective
with my audience why i felt that way
and hopefully compel them to try to
empathize with my perspective okay
that's the goal
and then you back out of there like
what's the most effective way to
accomplish that goal and that's where i
think i really made a mistake like i
don't think my video was effective
because it was too i was too like upset
and angry and emotional when i made that
video
and i think those sort of emotions
turned people off and i think a more
effective way would have done it to have
done it would have been like
to volunteer my perspective which i did
in that video
wrong but everything i said in that
video about how i feel about
yeah um the president i i still feel
that way
a lot of those things have really netted
out um he's kind of been the
you know the person that i foresaw him
being um so i could have been there was
a much more effective way to present
that
right and i also think like in that
effective way of presenting that like
and what made it so complicated i was
never like a fan of hers
she sucked no one was no one was and
that was that's why i think i was so
frustrated yeah
was it wasn't like look here's this
amazing candidate that you guys should
all know about
and here's this other guy who's not good
and here's why he's not good
i couldn't say that and i'm not
defending what i said
for the people that don't understand the
context casey made a video
back during the last election you had
basically said vote for
for hillary because trump it was less it
was it was don't vote for
trump yeah don't and here's why but that
wasn't the part that got me in trouble
but you had a sense of urgency i had a
sense of
and i also was like you sounded
emotional i was emotional i was also
really frustrated then with the youtube
community because the community at large
like given
the pro trumpers who i respect and i
understand
my dad voted for trump i have no beef
with people who have different political
positions than mine
but the pro-trumpers were really
intimidating leading up to the last
election like i know about you mentioned
one thing on twitter you get attacked
and that sucks
oh that's still true it's still true and
even just saying like even if i'm like
yeah i voted for hillary last which i i
readily admit to it's not like
secret but yeah um
people the pro trumpers are [ __ ] yeah
they're cool and it's scary
bro and scary they're they're the
craziest people out there
yeah and i see your point i feel like a
lot of youtubers
probably including us who are feeling
like it's better to not take sides
because you're going to divide your
audience
yeah and that felt that was upsetting
for me because like i guess
that was a thing for a while i i think
where you were coming from and i can see
maybe i'm putting words in your mouth
correct me if i'm wrong but like
it almost is like cowardice in a way
because truly the reason that a lot of
people
a lot of the reason that you don't want
to get involved in stuff like that is
because you don't want the heat
because you know that the people are
just so
uh so divided so deadly they're just no
not even that but the people that
oppose you are so bitter and they're so
relentless
and they will try to ruin your life for
opposing them so it's like
it's a combination of yeah is it worth
it of even going there but that's their
goal right to make it unworth
yeah and i think i felt like i was like
i felt like that at the time you wanted
to be like
screw these guys it was more just like
look if you if you have an opinion
if you don't have an opinion i get it no
big deal but if you have an opinion
you're scared to share it because you're
scared of the repercussions
you are doing a disservice and i think
like the way i just said it right here
just now like that's a diplomatic
appropriate way of saying it
and i think in that video it lacked that
kind of diplomacy i don't think i was
right about it
looking back do you see that as a like a
big moment in your
career like how do you how do you
perceive it looking back really at the
time it was
a big it felt like a big deal right
maybe
i guess people took made up quite a big
thing about it i mean i
i jumped on that i talked about it i
mean a lot of people talked about it
but it's the kind of thing that people
also move on you know kind of yeah i
mean i guess it also is just like
i mean politics is such a divisive thing
for it's largely absent i think within
the youtube community except for
the political channels which are so
political on both sides you know what i
mean like
i think phil defranco has like one of
the only really kind of
fair down the middle like a political
shows
but when you look at like the young
turks or you look at you know the more
conservative wars
infowars it's they're both super they're
they're really far on one side of the
spectrum
that's right but you kind of have to
because it's like
you got to get your people and you've
got to like kind of preach to the choir
in that sense and nobody really uh
nobody wants to listen to the fair and
balanced guy
they want their their views validated
they want their they want to be a part
of the community and they want to
you know what i'm saying it's like
seeing you've got cnn you've got fox
news
yeah i i this whole thing with mueller's
or not mueller
he's he's old news now yeah the uh
ukraine
the whistleblower whistleblower so i'm i
intentionally put on
i switch between cnn and fox news
because that's what i do i want to do
the same exactly i'm like i'm really
curious what they're saying
it's important to understand both and
it's just uh
but it's like that you know it's just
shocking the perception is so different
it's so i mean it's like also my
favorite thing to do with paul with
podcast rather is like i'll listen to a
really
liberal podcast you know like crooked
media has some great podcast
but then whatever i'm listening to on
that i thumb through like ben shapiro
and find him talking about the same
subject matter and i find that like
unless you expose yourself to really
extremes on both sides it's hard to get
an understanding of what other people
think yeah yeah and i do want to i do
value very much
you have to really understand their
argument if you're going to empathize
with them in any
yeah like the abortion thing is
something we've talked about here people
who
who oppose abortion literally
think you're murdering a baby what could
be worse than that it's like uh
so in very in in other ways you have to
understand
how they see because it's easy to be
like oh that's just insane these people
are crazy how do they believe that
but it's like when you realize that
they're saying abortion is
murdering a baby then it's like well
yeah if you think about it that way then
it's hard to
yeah and i think where it gets dangerous
is when you start to dismiss
people who have differing opinions from
yours because you're like well they
think different so they're just wrong
and you move on like that's not a
healthy thing
yeah that's the norm though right it's
become the norm and i think that's scary
i think that's scary like getting into
talking about the broad implications of
like the
the true egalitarianization or or
democratization of
communication the fact that like
everybody has he can have a youtube
channel everybody can
say whatever they want on twitter um
everybody can communicate whatever they
want to communicate
the things that go the furthest are the
most polarizing the most divisive like
the more extreme you can be the more
impactful your statement
and it produces this sort of
incentivization around
uh whether it's extremism or
sensationalism
that will be taken to its inevitable
conclusion i just don't know what that
is
and it's really scary it's like you know
who's who's really good at that is like
the president is really like donald
trump is one of like the best
i don't know how he's communicating he's
unbelievable at how he
he's like the the i don't know if i'm
saying this right the tail that's
wagging the entire dog
of the media world of the conversation
like he is unbelievably good at that
yeah i agree
and you see smart news outlets that
disapprove them just falling into line
like he puts out the bait and they run
right to the trap
yeah it's because they're they want
ratings and it's juicy and everybody
it's irresistible right
like dude like i'm i'm i love
i i'm just fascinated by how he's now i
want to see how he's spinning the
whistle blowing thing
and i just listened to like the new york
times podcast on the way over i could
talk about perspectives i have to listen
to the fox news one on the way back but
um this seems like a this is like a huge
deal
it just seems like a big deal to me the
d like the more they scratch the surface
but like here he
i gotta read you this specific tweet
this is how he
phrases it do you follow donald trump
yeah of course
i don't i can't okay how can i not but
this is how he phrases it
and this this is how his supporters see
it too right they go
um
this is dead air moment this is worth it
though dead air
this is important by the way ela the new
uh
teddy fresh line looks dope thank you
really dope thank you so much
i've been places i never saw oh that's
awesome
it's so good that's so awesome to hear
okay i can't
panicking i i want to give you guys a
bunch of stuff yeah outfit us
it's great cool it's just so good this
is such a fan
ethan this better be like well i thought
it would be better
the conversation i have we have seen you
um
supporting the yang gang i mean look
andrew yang i think is so
fantastic he's like he's fresh air right
yeah and it's like you know i think
people say to me
have said to me things along the lines
of like why are you supporting him he
doesn't stand a chance of
what he does though okay my response to
that is irrelevant
like true i do think he stands a chance
but let's suppose he doesn't stand a
chance
i still think it's worth elevating him
because he's bringing such an idea
brilliant perspective to things like he
i heard this breakdown of his universal
basic income
um and yeah he calls it a freedom
dividend
and i one i do think it's smart i do
support it but beyond the financial
implications of it he tied it to about
like human dignity
and the fact that like when you have
nothing you lack that dignity you lack
that compassion you lack that
understanding
and if everybody has just this this bare
minimum safety net
it will elevate kind of dignity it will
elevate the conversation it will elevate
and it was such like there's such
profundity to that concept
the idea that a president like a
presidential candidate could run on
something
that's that you know it's that like
human
that's that about elevating the humans
like the way that we all
feel yeah i also love huge fan i love
that i
love it i love how he everything
connects when you listen to his solution
it connects everything like mental
health all of it
you know love that guy career is
changing just
everything is a part of the picture yeah
it really
for me first of all he's definitely the
dark horse he's the only guy raising
dude he's not like eight percent
that should it's insane he's never born
and cnn and they still don't know
they still don't mention him you know
why i love yang
he even bernie sanders who i'm a fan of
now
almost looks his approach was almost
uh dated because andrew yang is the only
person who is
looking actually into the future these
guys are trying to address these
problems that we're facing now but yeah
andrew yang is the only one who's saying
in 50 years
in 20 years but also it's not even
in 20 years right a lot of it is already
happening he's right we we
misclassify a lot of the problems we see
in society
for example the stuff we blame
immigrants for that's what he says it's
a robot
problem not an immigrant probably yeah
and nobody else is nobody else is even
acknowledging that
yeah plus his math hat yeah i love that
and plus like math is such a good like
naga is pretty great
like make america great again i think is
one of the best campaign slogans ever
but ronald reagan created make america
great yeah
oh really yeah it's old that's like 30
years old it's still amazing he bit that
from reagan he bit that be careful
it's such a good one but i think math
might be even better
make america think harder it's so
virtuous and amazing yeah it is great
yeah i rock the math hat a lot of people
ask me i gotta get that math i gotta get
it
yang is a great guy friend of the show i
got to bring him on again
i have to say seeing him
on a show like yours
shows a kind of understanding of what's
needed to
reach people totally a lot of like
bernie sanders was given so much credit
for going on joe rogan's podcast which
certainly like god bless him was great
and i have to say like i'm pretty versed
when it comes to politics and i learned
about bernie more from joe's podcast
than maybe anywhere else
but andrew had done it weeks prior and
he was on there like six months was he a
year before he did your show
and then when i was still in new york i
i dm'd him
and i was like dear mr yang i wasn't
actually i was like andrew i was like
i'd love to do an interview with you
like
same day text me back he's like great
casey would you mind if i connected you
with someone
yeah it's like [ __ ] you are
running for president you can connect
with whoever you
want just the g and i think that that
really demonstrates not just an
understanding of like how do you
communicate with people but like
you know i don't know what your
demographic is but i assume it's younger
than cnns and how important it is to
communicate directly with that audience
as to where they are
he came here with this whole staff and
they're very they're young people and
they're the kind of people who know who
people like we are so
when i tweeted at him i was like hey
would you like to come on our podcast
um uh he's got people
he's got good people to say this is
important yeah by the way he deleted
that tweet
he delete it the president can't delete
tweets
that's why he deleted a tweet yeah he
said uh
why the [ __ ] would he delete that what a
what he's kind of a [ __ ] isn't he
like just to be honest like he's kind of
a whiny [ __ ] too like lately
he just whines a lot this is what he
said uh he said democrats are trying to
destroy their
party and all it stands for fight hard
he said republicans
he says democrats are trying to destroy
the republican party and all it stands
for
stick together play their game and fight
hard republicans
our country is at stake why would he
delete that
i i don't know it makes you uh wonder
doesn't doesn't it
i mean there's a lot of things he should
be deleting if he's looking out for his
own well-being
this is the kind of rhetoric where he's
like i'm i'm
i'm under the microscope for for
something
really bad we're going to investigate
find out if it's true the whistleblower
complaint
but his response is it's a conspiracy
we have to stand together they're trying
to destroy our country
fight hard well look i mean i think wow
the real threat to him
here is that um
if the if the implications or if like
if enough comes out of this
whistleblower situation
where it becomes unequivocal like
there's no you either admit that what he
did was wrong
or you're wrong like it's that black and
white which never happened to mueller
investigation
obstruction of justice like what did
mueller say like this
if he had not committed obstruction of
justice i would have said so it's like
does that mean he did
it's like you speak [ __ ] english i
didn't understand i think he said he
said
i know what he was saying but it was
complicated it was easy it was easy to
argue that like this is all
noise yes but if this comes out so black
and white
i think the real feel fear here and the
concern for the president is that like
if it's so unequivocal that the
republicans are like okay i'm not just
going to just keep playing the violin on
the deck of the titanic here like i'm
not going to ride this thing down
and then they start to come out and be
criticize him like the whole house of
cards could fall quickly
and that's a scary process but he's
already the spin has already
he's already ahead of that because he's
going the whistle blower is a partisan
hack
he's a spy um right but did you watch
the interview with the acting dni
yesterday yeah yes
um not the interview the the that was
the here
congressional hearing yeah yeah um it's
tough
like he can say that about mueller's 12
angry
democrats democrats which i don't think
was actually true but the point is like
you can throw you can spray a fog
machine at that and make it blurry
but something like this like it's it's
you know i don't know
yeah you disagree i like to i like i
would like to think that's true because
what i
the accusations that i see are are just
uh you know textbook corruption
it's not you know come on he's but
teflon stick to donald trump
well that's what i'm saying okay yeah
i'm saying one
the whistleblower is a partisan hack
we're already spinning that uh narrative
two okay even if the complaint is true i
see them saying this too already
even if the complaint is true then well
all i was doing was trying to
investigate joe biden's son's corruption
it wasn't about uh trying to benefit me
i was trying to yeah that's
their joe biden was uh doing corrupt
things in ukraine and i was
i was just investigating for the good of
our country what aboutism is incredibly
effective isn't it
you know well people people who are in
people they're in all in on donald
so i mean they'll grab on and hold on
but even like i look at my dad
and i ask him about something like that
and he just cites all like supporting
donald trump
and he just cites nothing but what about
ism and i
i think it's really interesting because
of how just how effective it is and i
have to say like
you know like during the 2016 campaign
he made the whole thing about like what
about her
what about her what about and it was
wildly effective
yeah it was wildly effective yeah so in
a situation like this it yeah i imagine
that's going to be his course of action
and
i think you're right it does stand a
chance of like yeah
he's yeah he's good at that being
teflontan too
yeah i'm sorry to interrupt but uh we
got to go to break okay thank you dan
appreciate that okay we're gonna go to a
quick break we'll be right back we're
gonna get off politics yeah and we're
gonna talk more
about um
i ignite i can't even say because it's
so good
what are we getting okay gotta wait and
find out i cannot wait
when it comes to meat ela it's more than
just texture
and taste okay there's other things you
need to
factor in there's hidden cost of low
quality meat instead you've got
environmental costs you've got weird
flavors it's all bad
but quality humanely raised meat it
needs to be important to everybody
it's better for you it's better for the
ammo it's better for the environment
that's what's the beauty of butcher box
i'm talking butcher box
they're going to send you a ridiculous
amount of meat dude
9 to 11 pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meals it comes frozen and
dry ice baby packed fresh shipped frozen
vacuum sealed
you can cust customize it however you
like whatever cut you like
i'm talking i'm talking 100 grass-fed
finished beef free-range organic chicken
heritage breed pork
wild caught salmon that's what i'm
talking about
and some people can't even find that
high quality meats in their grocery
stores maybe
a lot of people don't have access to you
know grass-fed beef
beef that isn't s slammed full of
hormones
as a you know it's a it's a that's what
butcher box is so beautiful they'll ship
it right to your door
humanely made humanely raised healthier
better it's it's a beautiful thing
uh it's a no-brainer it's the best meat
ship right to your door which means one
last trip to the grocery store
you got all the good oh i got bacon too
come on
it's the most affordable and convenient
way to get healthy humanely raised meat
with butcher buck you get the highest
quality
meat for just around six dollars a meal
they have free shipping everywhere
nationwide except for those
idiots in alaska and hawaii doesn't that
suck to be alaskan or why they can't get
any of the good free shipping look at
this
here's my box just to give you guys an
idea this was this is what the foods
this is what the meat sees before before
it's eaten
here's the dry ice to keep it fresh
everything was
frozen solid alaskan socket salmon look
how like that
it's rich red color grass-fed beef ribs
steak at the you know what
ribeye steak you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm trying to say look at
all that meat dude
bacon thighs pork ground beef
chicken breast and that's steak we made
it was delicious
it was so good unbelievable i mean give
me a break here folks
here's a deal that i've never heard
before butcher box is offering new
members ground beef for life
take that in it's like willy wonka with
the everlasting gobstopper
yes ground beef for life that's two
pounds
of ground beef in every box for the life
of this subscription
plus twenty dollars off the first box
damn
but that's just what i needed play
ground beef what's yourbox.com
h3 or enter promo code h3 at checkout
that's butcherbox.com
h3 or enter promo code h3 at checkout
you're going to need this lifetime
splayground
you know that socks are the number one
most requested clothing i
item in homeless shelters interestingly
also
in my bedroom it's the one number one
most good does that mean i'm homeless
i look homeless well bombast is on a
mission to change
that they created the most comfortable
socks in the history of feet and for
every pair of socks purchased
bombass donates a pair to someone in
need
designed with special comfort
innovations colors
patterns lengths and styles bombass
are perfect for the whole family get
your hands on a pair of
bombass socks and your feet will thank
you
did you know that bomb bass has donated
over 20 million pairs
and counting that's a lot well there's
not a lot of socks
they must be good they're they're made
from super soft natural cotton and every
pair is designed with arch support
and a seamless toe like that a seamless
toe
yeah because you know how sometimes you
get that oh on your pinky
that's cool yeah and a cushioned foot
bed that's supportive but not too thick
my new favorites well don't put words in
my mouth they said my new favorites are
their new mirror
wool socks designed to be breathable dry
and never
itchy and just the right amount of
thickness yeah that's totally something
you would say
my new though mirror wool socks they're
they like those
with tons of different colors patterns
lengths and styles bomb bass
also make the perfect gif for everybody
on your list
oh that's right the holidays are right
around the season well here we go guys
i gotta i gotta offer for you save 20
on your first purchase when you shop at
bombass.com
h3 that's b o m b
bomb ass bomb ass
dot com bomb bass it's just one ass
though
yeah it's like bomb ass but one s bomb
bass
b-o-b-b-o-m-b-a-s dot com slash h3 to
save
20 bombass dot com
h3
hey welcome back all right i promised
some real juicy stuff but
i click baited you i got nothing ethan
is out of here
ethan's out of breath because he and his
little boys during the break while you
and i were here really dialed in
the little boy's room how does that how
do you comfortable in the little boy's
room
men's room that feels like that's better
now
men's room the little boys what's going
on in there little boys
that makes sense but you got to shake
that once they grow up
if you didn't have kids that would be
weird yeah it gets weird is it weird
that my look my son is 21
he's a great he's a six foot two-inch
grown-ass man yeah in college
frankly thanks for telling me yeah
i really imagine he saved me by telling
you that
all right bring on the juice man i'm
ready
first of all you're in la you're mr new
york what are you yeah
dude why are you here you know everybody
asked me and about
like how much i'm missing new york i
don't miss new york at all except for
you just said like i'm mr new york i
miss it being part of my identity
like there's something about like new
york is so harsh that anyone who lives
in new york they're like
nice yeah you made it for i feel like
it's
not that you may be like you're going
for it you are going it is so
there's no living there only surviving
yes so if someone's surviving that city
it means they're doing it for a reason
and that is an admirable thing
so do you feel more comfortable here in
l.a yeah you kidding me it's like
vacation
every single day the life quality of
here i live at the beach
that sounds good to me it's incredible
like wake up play with my kids
drop them off at school like go surfing
go for a hike
go home like it's like it's literally
like vacation like
my father-in-law says that he harbors
guilt because the quality of life here
is so
good he moved here too yeah right oh so
that's the reason like that why we moved
why we picked l.a
was found candace's parents moved here a
year and a half ago or she lives here
they all live here they're all very
happy here my big brother who has a baby
who's the same age as my baby
he lives here yeah
um how was uh candace doing how's the
family doing in l.a
um good c plus
c plus yeah there's problems there's
problems but like c plus they're
perfectly
packing no no that's a d plus it's oh
yeah it's a big
move so it's a big change but she's also
a new yorker
right i made it through ten years how
are you if you how what's your rating
a plus oh a plus a plus to the point
ethan where no [ __ ] i cannot have this
conversation with candace
like this morning we got back from new
york last night she was there for work
for four days she got back this morning
i was like you've been quiet and she's
like well i can't tell you how good my
trip was and how much i
love new york because you're just going
to say to me well i love l.a
i'm like oh you guys have coastal like
big
she's right we do we do i'm too you're a
coupon she's big yeah
which means which means i go down first
but at the end of the day we both lose
and is it and so you're what uh your
wife is currently breastfeeding right
no i thought we weren't going to talk
about this no we don't breastfeed
i mean i don't mean to say it like that
oh no she physically
my wife physically because i'm just i'm
just trying to that's a swerve
i'm just talking about new york and i
like right i'm not trying to go into the
breastfeeding thing
i just wanted to kind of explore why she
may be
not enjoying the l.a lifestyle i i think
there's myriad reasons one i think she
she does enjoy aspects of the la
lifestyle in a big way
two and that's probably the biggest
factor i kind of spent like the last
year of my life in new york
buttoning things up like i was checked
out like no joke my wife
literally put me in therapy in new york
city because i was having such a
hard time being there for the last year
i was just done i was like
the toast had popped up from the toaster
oven i was out
especially because we bought our house
in los angeles a year over a year ago
you were just
dreaming of that house yeah so for eight
months i'm just in new york being like
freezing my ass off being like i have
this really cool place in los angeles
that i want to start my new life in
yeah and she never did that in fact like
her momentum in new york city was so
entrenched in new york city that when we
left
she just felt like it was and it is like
she has a company there with employees
and
i have 368 in new york but i have
someone really capable of my partner
there running it so i have
more distance than she has um so there's
like there's a whole bunch of those
factors yeah and then on top of that
a lot of the aspects that i love about
la she just doesn't
she doesn't partake in if that makes
sense i mean to be cryptic what i mean
is like
in my neighborhood i have 10 friends not
weed
um partake candace does smoke weed she
partakes partnership sounds like a weird
thing
i mean like i have like a dozen friends
that all live in my neighborhood
and like we hang out like children like
go to the beach together
we exercise together and ride bikes
together do you think she's feeling left
out a little bit
um i think she's feeling left out on the
fact that i'm
i'm so happy here and i'm so excited to
be here and she's not
and that causes resentments not that
she's not i can be friends with her if
she wants because i have no friends
i have like one friend i appreciate like
i really want friends
that's the beginning yeah i mean one
friend that's a great place
it's a great place to start and yeah i'd
appreciate that
you just invoice me for it or whatever
i can then motivate you for that but
like let me know yeah her friend right
steve
sorry i know she does delicious but no
overall it's good the kids are happy
like they really enjoy it like that's
good my daughter went to
a summer camp that was at the beach like
how crazy is that that's awesome
like so the bigger concern was like i
can i can handle
candace's stress about this move because
it makes sense it's rational
i was really worried about the kids
freaking out oh yeah and they have it
like i think my daughter's really
excited to be here
ellie's unbelievable that's how i feel
about it i sometimes
when i when i'm here and it's like i
feel like this is so nice
that i start to understand where white
privilege comes from
because like i sometimes i feel like oh
that's why privilege like i am
i feel so privileged sometimes you know
because i'm
and i'm like i hate that natural state
of being really
yeah exactly privilege yeah i'm not that
kind of person
i will say of white privilege but i i
feel like this is euphoria here i say it
a lot because
like especially coming from israel i
don't know it's everything is so nice
here
yeah i'm sure there are people who are
living
impoverished and shitty places in in
america
but not here baby except for the
homeless people
yeah just pretty think about it it's
pretty simple
but no like that what you're talking
about i
feel like especially since i got here my
focus has been finding a footing and
like spending time with the kids
spending time with the family like
really embracing the things that i was i
never did in new york
and it does show like just how
privileged of a life
you have like until you like stop the
sprint and like
you're just saying they're catching your
breath looking around it's hard to
realize just how special
right and like a word that i use that
hard-working successful people don't
like to use
is lucky yeah like [ __ ] that hustle
hard work like all of it's [ __ ] luck
is 98
of it being at the right place the right
time and the two percent is talent and
hard work and all that other stuff
like come on i really don't know how i
feel about that
okay i'll go three percent but i won't
go i make [ __ ] cool
youtube videos and that warrants this
insane life that i have
no no one can make your videos well i
appreciate it even though everyone knows
but also you're like you're a psycho bro
and i mean that's a compliment like
you you posted a video every day for 800
days i mean
that's not luck that's like you
literally i would imagine the
thing that i thought when i was watching
your vlogs like for 800 days in a row is
like
this guy doesn't see his family probably
well that was the truth right but
so have you ever met like a have you
ever met like a coal miner or a
construction worker who's worked
ot 800 days in a row because they exist
have i ever met a coal miner
yeah you know anything no i don't really
either but i do know this
coal miners work way [ __ ] harder than
a vlogger that's okay or a podcast
but they don't get to live these
ridiculous lives that we get to live in
new york
and l.a and that's what i mean by but
you um
you did start a whole new genre
well i appreciate it i appreciate all of
you popularized let's say right
popularized right sounded more like
would you say you started it or
popularized it
you know i don't know legacy is a funny
thing i'll say start it for you because
you don't want to say it
for yourself i'll say it for you i i
will say that like
i think a lot of the initial success of
my
youtube vlog was the fact that
people hadn't seen anything that looked
or felt like that before and yeah and
and so frequently with such consistency
it was a big part of it yeah
like if you remember back to vlogging
which was still like a strange word
people didn't even know that word now it
just means youtuber
but vlogging in 2014 2015 was literally
like
a couple of people who lived interesting
lives and shared it via a
point-and-shoot camera
but it was very literal very very
limited linear and very literal
this is what i'm doing right now follow
along with me right
and my approach was never that it was
always like okay 24 hours is such a
long amount of time and i know i can
pull five to 10 minutes of rich
interestingness from that to share so
it's like fundamentally a different
approach and i think that's what
when people like yourself you generously
credit me with starting something new i
think that that approach
was really fresh on the platform and
that approach has been really widely
adopted
but i think that if i didn't do it then
somebody else would have like
i don't think there's anything
particularly revolutionary about that
i just think it's sort of an evolution
of the process and i think that i
found the right place at the right time
yeah exactly getting back to luck yeah
like if i try
if i did my vlog now
but that would be like the luck
it's three percent either
[Music]
he doesn't believe it's three percent i
do you're coming from the dude that runs
15 hours a day
and used to work 22 you you would go to
you would say
i have a stop watch when i sleep and i
said
i had to get the work done yeah your day
is not 24 hours it's like
48. she's trying to experiment but let's
um
let's stop sucking casey okay no no it's
not three percent you don't believe that
i do
i do jerry seinfeld doesn't believe in
luck and i'm
jerry i follow jerry seinfeld okay
you just got [ __ ] owned i mean if you
wanted to keep the date in this week
no i don't i don't okay but i am
fascinated
now that i've got you here i can ask you
i can tell and you've you've just told
me i do wonder about like
the amount of work you put in your
dedication to your
job at the time how that did affect your
family and your home life and
and essentially uh the consequences of
working so much i mean it affected it
tremendously
and i think that the working so much was
only a small part of it i think a bigger
part of it was the fact that
you know my family was such a big part
of the vlog for so long
like when my older daughter now turned
one or like 11 months we stopped putting
her in any videos in any social media
so the first time when she turned one
was when the vlog was like
four or five months old and i realized
that like whoa
there's an audience here people are
watching this i don't want to put my
kids out there in this capacity anymore
i stopped putting them out there
um but even so that aside you know my
relationship with my wife was a big part
of the narrative my relationship
with my kids as far as me being a father
was a big part of it yeah
and i think the social implications of
that were as
um impactful if not more than
the sheer hours i was working and the
implications of that were things like
if candace and i weren't in a good place
in our marriage there's no [ __ ] way
she was gonna like
be chipper when i pointed a camera at
her and by chipper i mean willing
in any capacity i mean anything but her
putting her hand over the lens saying
turn that [ __ ] thing off
so i you know i used to like avoid
fights with her avoid arguments with her
i very
i very deliberately used to
quell any disagreements we'd have
because i needed her for content
yeah and looking back crazy what a crazy
thing that is
yeah it's like i'm i'm disturbing the
the way that the world should work
because i need
content yeah and i don't think that i'm
like a particularly like
maniacal person but it does make me stop
and think when i see
much more invasive family vloggers i
don't mean this as a judgment i mean
this is a genuine curiosity but people
who rely so much on their children
who aren't babies but are four five six
seven eight years old
they rely on them for content i was
trying to rely on my wife who's my
age and i could rationalize for content
and i could feel the burden i was
putting on her
i have the same thoughts and um
yeah i don't necessarily want to like
call out anyone or make them look bad
but it feels wrong to me
to rely on a child even even if it seems
like the child wants to be involved and
it's fun
they just don't know yet the full
picture like an adult
knows you guys know the eb family yeah
exactly that's right yeah
we're familiar with them yeah and
they're really nice they're really
[ __ ] lovely yeah yeah yeah
i love those i think they're doing
everything right is where i'm going with
them and this is a huge priority of
theirs and we've had this discussion
before
and they go to a really extreme place
which is like what are the labor laws
about putting your kids in videos like
what how do you quantify the value that
they're bringing to the content
are there is that value going back to
them
well that's the point is that there's
nothing everybody's looking at and then
these
revenues being generated because these
children are creating content where does
that money go
is it parents that are keeping that or
is it i think these are all really smart
questions that can be asked without
pointing fingers
but just to bring it back to what you
were asking ethan is it was just like
only i was aware of it at the time but
only in retrospect do i look back and
it's like wow
the destructiveness of that on my own
marriage and relationship was
profound and i talked to my wife about
now and she says with no equivocation
she was like
you have no not to me because i did know
but she says publicly she's like you
have no idea how close to divorce we
were
because it was like when i wasn't
superficially being nice to get her to
behave to be in my
videos i was working just working
right um and that that that in itself
that's much more
objective and how how did it affect the
relationship with your son too because
your son your age different is very
small what's the age difference between
you and you say like 16 years
16 years we're almost the same age as
which is so totally crazy every time i
see you guys together it's
really something i mean yeah you guys
must have a really unique relationship
for that purpose but
i've seen videos of you kind of like
celebrating his birthday or something
and you're vlogging the experience
did he also feel the brunt of that well
it was it's always been easier with owen
because he's old and even like you go
way back and you look at like my hbo
show and you go back and look at my
really old content that he's in
um he's always old enough to sort of
consent and sign off
so like you know when i think of some of
the more he went to college when i was
about
i think a year into the vlog a little
more than that and
when you know you sort of look into that
content like you're not driving
cross-country or drop them off at school
there's always kind of a discussion
like you don't want to make videos you
mind if i make videos about this stuff
do you want to be in them do you not
want me to do it
and he could always give me a very
thoughtful response which i think
without exception was always like yeah
let's make videos did he ever say no
owens never said no in fact recently
and this both made me sad and then
really proud recently he was like can we
take a trip together
because we haven't made a video together
in a really long time and it made me sad
because we haven't made a video together
in a long time but it also made me like
it was the first time they really sort
of showed me unprovoked that he's not
just doing this
he thinks he's supposed to or he's not
just doing this because he thinks
i want him to do it but it's something
that he does like
yeah and like it's very different from
like francine my daughter now being like
i want to be on youtube
which she says she says that's me
everyone say that though now
she's four [ __ ] and the reason why is
because like she watches jojo siwa
god bless her i love jojo um and she's
like i can do that
and she could and she wants to do it
which is ironic because we don't have
what do you think about that
for me it's like a hard no until she's
like
18 or something like that um it's just
because
i know that she has no idea what it
means i wrote
34 or whatever 35 when i started really
putting myself out there on youtube i
had no idea what it meant
so how can a child have any
understanding of what i mean even jojo
who i adore and i never take an
opportunity i never miss an opportunity
to say how much i appreciate her
i genuinely do she's an amazing person
like
the burden that's on her and the
criticism that she gets for who she is
like for being 15 years old and be able
to handle that in any capacity
shows how tough he is but to subject a
kid to that seems really
i wonder about the kind of
the like the effect that that being a
youtuber has
on you psychologically which is
something that
everyone at this table has been through
i think
i think me and you particular have have
gone through a lot psychologically from
i i know i have
i think i i can hear obviously you have
to correct me where i'm wrong
but um there is such a
there's such a i want to say like
stress damn uh damage is kind of
subjective but
there's a lot of like pressure on on
your self identity and you really put
everything you think
of yourself in an enormous
pressure cooker and it's
breaks a lot of people it's broken me
several times
and um like for i haven't posted on h3
productions a while we're doing this
podcast now
you haven't posted on your channel in a
long time you know
i wonder what your thoughts are about
that what what
it's like it doesn't seem to exist so
intensely in other mediums
of entertainment and video production
but
this whole thing about creator burnout
is
related i think to it and you do see a
lot of turnover of
youtubers too you see a lot of youtubers
coming up and going out
um it's just it's
people can't possibly understand
the enormous you know the enormity of
pressure
that you undergo when you put yourself
out there like that yeah and i think
that
one i think it's so new everything you
just said is right but i also think that
it is exasperated by the fact that it's
so new
this is never like we've had movie stars
and actresses for almost 100 years
you know we can look back in 1919 like
when right when talkies were starting to
come up
movie stars were movie stars then they
were famous and there was some
understanding of that but this is so
new where your own fame your
own notoriety your own success financial
and otherwise is all within
your soul control for the most part um
compared to traditional mediums
traditional entertainment mediums
so like yeah you're not just burdened
with like your physical presence
because you don't have a publicist you
don't have a pr person you're physically
putting yourself out there you're
literally putting yourself out there
every day
but you're also consumed with the burden
of the actual production
you're not showing up on a set when you
get a call sheet this is your operation
like we're sitting in your studio right
now and you guys pay rent in the studio
you pay everybody's
salary that works out of your space
um and so i think like the burdens are
holistic
and that's never existed before in this
medium you're an actor and you act
you're a director and you direct
you own a studio and you want a studio
but this is some sort of an amalgam of
every aspect of
of the world of entertainment tied into
one and then that amalgam
that amalgamation is is is distributed
via global
network that can be reached by more
people than any any television network
has ever had access to
so when you look at it in those sort of
extreme but literal terms
you of course [ __ ] 20 year olds and
18 year olds who put themselves out
there
are going to are going to crack they're
going to buckle under this sort of
pressure
and i think that i'm an interesting case
study in that because i did work in the
traditional
facets of media for a dozen years plus
before i jumped into this world
so i have some understanding of what the
more traditional elements are like and
then i have a really good understanding
of what this world is like
and yeah and the burden is is wild
it's wild and it's i think it's
underappreciated in a way that
i remember justin bieber came out a
couple years ago and said he's not doing
meet and greets anymore
i don't know justin but i was so proud
of him because he was so eloquent in the
way he communicated that
he's matured a lot yeah he's mature but
the way he said he did something like
it's not meaningful for the fan to meet
me for one second it's not meaningful
for me
but it stresses me out and it's very
burdensome and i'm gonna lose a lot of
money by not doing it but i'm not gonna
do it
he was like he was scrutinized for that
he was chastised for that his fans
called him as like
we do everything we give your career and
this is all we want you won't give it to
us
i thought he was so right i thought that
he was so perfect in that
in the way he dealt with that the man
grades are so tough we just
came from one in new york and the line
was so long
and we we want to make it a meaningful
moment
you know so we actually take a few
minutes to talk to each one and really
you know give them like an interaction
but trying to churn them
and then we feel bad because and then
yeah and then we felt bad because by the
time we left the line was still the same
size
you know we're there for five hours and
um it's a tough like i don't know how
you do it right
but i think i think doing that
constantly would just feel really bad
it would i think i don't think there is
a way to do it that's right
i don't i won't do it i've done them
before and now like i do a lot of public
speaking and things like that
it's always in the contract like casey
is to do a vip meet and greet
with up to 300 people for and like for
me it's a hard no
i'll lose a very valuable job over that
because
i've also gotten like crazy as i'm sure
you guys have like
you get paranoid i really care about
this stuff like did we head at our meet
and greet we had like
armed guards five armed guards we do
this i don't [ __ ] i don't i'm
good you definitely get paranoid yeah
you get pre and it's like you're
paranoid about safety but then like
they're psychological
other aspects for like emotional
paranoia or what these people want from
me what does this one picture need like
i need a moment right now to catch my
breath i need to do a fresh piece of gum
everyone's watching yeah why is
everybody like
me my hands are dirty are there germs on
my hands it's just like
shaking you start to go crazy you start
to go [ __ ] people
breathing on you and you can smell them
like that degree of intimacy with
strangers who know
you yeah like you don't know anything
but this like when you're doing 300
people in 90 minutes all this shit's
going through your head i cracked
they're and i just i won't do it
meet and greets are intense they're very
they're for for the record everyone who
was there is very wholesome it's nice
yes to see up close people tell you that
you're working yeah
right that that is very impactful on me
but i think we've only done three in our
career because
a lot i can stand on a stage in front of
three thousand people and be
cool as a cucumber super comfortable
give me a talk you put on a movie that a
million people might see
super comfortable with that the minute i
step off that stage
and people come over to shake my hand i
start to panic panic
and it's true like in every aspect of my
life and i don't remember always being
like that
i never remember having this sort of
anxiety i don't go out
at all i don't go out to dinners let's
catch up let's go to this party get
invited i don't do
any of that stuff and i don't think i
ever had that before i think it's a big
like i need to
yeah because before nobody nobody cares
about you
no nobody cares about you and that's a
very comforting thing nobody wants to
come and say hi and
you're not worried about who's noticing
you yeah yeah you're very you're very
conscious of everything when you're out
in public you know
um but you brought this up ethan you
said
you brought this up and i responded by
saying this is such a new phenomenon yes
so i was jerome jar former biggest viner
on the planet amazing jerome jar
he is one of the like most incredible
people i've ever met he dropped his
entire
very valuable social media career to
become a philanthropist and
he's been in bangladesh for the last
year helping the rohingyas who are being
persecuted like he's an unbelievable
individual
and we're in my house and he's like
telling me about what it was like living
in bangladesh what it was like
essentially living as a refugee and
helping these refugees
and i'm staring at him and i'm sort of
drifting off thinking back to like my
friend jerome five years ago who used to
make the goofiest
vines and and then i was thinking about
like nash grier and ash greer great guy
like he and i have been texting he's
having a baby right now if he didn't
already have it like
he's grown up and all stuff and i'm
thinking back like nash was this
teenager on vine
he's through silly things and girls
loved him so so cute
and i thought about the fact that like
we're just starting to see the first
generation of
youtubers that dominated and they're
starting to fade away
and what happens to them now but vine we
absolutely have a generation of these
social media superstars viners
who are no longer and like what's
happening to them now and understanding
the psychology of that
and we all have movie stars from like
the 90s that were huge that kind of went
away and we can look at their lives now
but we've never had that in the world of
social media
and that to me is fantastically
interesting yeah question that i
think about too is like these movie
stars that are no longer they probably
made enough money to live
forever social media people not
necessarily not necessarily if you make
a couple million bucks and then
and then you then your career is over
for whatever reason
that's not enough dude especially
without you especially if you make that
money when you're young and it feels
like
an endless amount of it and also it's
not not that many
social media stars have made a couple
million bucks right and that's a lot
that's even a lot that says
that's what i mean i mean it's more like
you're getting ten thousand dollar brand
deals once or twice a month
which is an ungodly amount of money yeah
yeah and that's more than my parents
have ever made and it's more than their
parents
and you're like [ __ ] this is incredible
i can live i'm rich i'm rich
yeah and then one day it sort of dries
up what do you do what do you do
so i think you know what you do you
become mario lopez yeah i've seen that
guy
incredible career incredible career
lopez is on like every day
like we were in the hotel and he's doing
like the hotel promo
you know mario lopez from saved by the
bell they probably have residuals though
they have some ones
i don't know maybe not but the point is
like that's amazing he's really found a
career i was at
universal studios with my kids the other
day like he was there like
with entertainment tonight or an exact
health show he's on but for us it's not
the same
no one wants to no one wants our face on
anyone i'm not doing that
i cannot
couple years now this is it baby
there's no next like i need to i need to
be good for life because after this
i'm not going to be a bagger at ralph's
i can't be a bagger at ralph's bro
and i'm not going to do anything else
what am i qualified to do whole foods
i'm going to be of whole foods now we're
talking well that's
that's very premium i will say but but
do you know how much [ __ ] i'll get
i can't just go bag [ __ ] now like even
if i wanted to
you know how much [ __ ] i'm going to get
from p shoppers there was a really
interesting article a couple years ago
and it was about like
medium i think they called a
middle-class social media stars
something like that but it was about a
youtuber and she
um at the time this was years ago she
was like i'm not making enough money off
of my youtube channel
to not work a day job but i can no
longer work in starbucks because so many
people are coming in being like whoa
aren't you that youtuber
and it was an interesting phenomenon to
study i've been there
i've been there i'm not there now
thankfully but for a long time in our
career
we were both too fame
too famous and but not rich enough there
was a crossover there where
and now you're just famous enough and
rich enough yes i'm i'm we're [ __ ] i
mean we're doing that i drove in on the
gatsby i know
i know i know how well you're doing it
is vivid
3 500 bucks we dropped on that okay
that's insane
that's improper you use toyota for 3 500
that's what i'm saying dude no i'm rich
thank you for noticing you need one
though i do i need a full fleet of them
i had i was talking with a friend
recently he was like
struggling a very successful guy but he
doesn't know what's it
doesn't know what's an idiot doesn't
know what's next or where he's going
and we talked about this idea of like
when you find your perfect
fit in your career um
like what that is and what that means
and he was thinking as like i haven't
found it yet
and that's frustrating for me and i
genuinely
am concern's not the right word but i
think often that like
what if that vlog which felt so right to
me when i was making it every day for
those 800 days like
felt so right was like the ultimate
express creative expression for me
like what if that was my high water mark
i mean i don't think i'm gonna be
bagging at ralph's anytime soon but like
yep oh i think about that too you know
as i sit here well it was until it
wasn't
yeah exactly because you started
obviously your whole family was starting
to
see the consequences and the way it was
coming next you know but there's a time
and place like i have that feeling too
but so i was doing h3 videos and i know
that's what
people enjoy the people who love that
and they get lots of views and it's nice
but there's just a certain point where i
just couldn't do it anymore
the format was still i was felt
uninspired it didn't feel good
it was performing well it was always
doing well but like it just
it just wasn't working and that's why we
we've gone all in on the vlog it's
because
yeah sorry the podcast got excited for a
minute
this is kind of just a vlog with one
camera right a lot of talking stationary
yeah
i need more time lapses but um
i feel i felt like that time and place
at least for the time being
was was that was it it had its time and
place and that was it and i had
and i had to go try something new now
which is what this is you peaked at vape
nation
yeah yeah dude even today and the meet
and greet everyone wants to throw up the
vape name
yeah i don't feel bad about it no you
and you should be proud of it you
created that and yeah by the same way
about
the vlog the only thing that's like a
little bit
difficult to really understand and
comprehend is that like
that's what your audience sees and
that's what they expect like i'm working
on something now that couldn't be
it's pretty far from a youtube video
like i'm working on a feature-length
documentary
and i think it's gonna be great i think
it has real opportunity we're super
excited about it i don't know
i'm just working right now i just want
to make it great okay um
interesting but like is is it going to
be as good as my
vlog i don't know but i know the
audience that love the vlog might not
love this
you gotta you gotta race the seasons of
your life
yeah i appreciate that and you're right
and that's what i'm doing but it is
still
a little bit scary like i'm you know you
can't go back you can't go back and do
it
you know what i mean you as a person
keep evolving and you can't be that same
person that was making that's right
right you got to be like things change
in your life you change
you grow up you know years ago and you
become a different person
the audience is uh
the thing is you can't you can't you
have to try your best not to let the
audience dictate your content
because the reason that they like your
content the reason they watch you begin
with is because it's a genuine
expression of yourself
that's the best content that's and so if
you
you lose some you gain some new ones but
ultimately as an artist you have to be
as true to yourself as possible you have
to ignore
everything yeah and i've gotten pretty
good i have to say i
feel zero pressure from my audience i
feel it elsewhere
it's pressure from my audience to be
creating content where do you feel it
right now yeah i mean like financially
and i
was i wanted to ask you do you have an
income right now i mean
i don't think i do i mean obviously you
have passive income for
everybody not just content but also you
know like i've done
i've got my my i've got my hands in a
million projects at all times i do a lot
of investing and a lot of things that i
think are
sort of my long-term opportunities you
don't have an active income
i don't have an active income right now
how does that feel fine it's fine
um i think but how's your baseline
you're still you're still
like spending goldie goldie no no like
you're the money you bring in every
month
i'm fine you're gold it's okay yeah i'm
in the black is that the good one yeah
in the black i'm in the black what's the
block you would think that it would be
green but they
being in the rock being in the red means
when you're okay red is like you're not
making as much as you're spending no
yeah and black is like okay yeah i'm
okay i mean
i i but it's not like that should be
blue
okay should not be black i think green
green green means go no green
is more money greener is like no green
is good you're making money that's what
yes
but the okay should be blue and not
black no not okay
black is it's black and red so i'm in
the blue okay so i've been in the blue
now
no not the blue um no i mean it's
stressful because like
you know i do worry that you know my
most valuable asset is my youtube
channel
and i appreciate that and i think in
order to like be able to sort of
it's not just adsense it's a brand
opportunities that i have which i love
those
i would never gotten to fly behind a
drone in a santa suit if i wasn't able
to work with brands i would have never
been able to like turn a shopping mall
into a
playground for underprivileged kids if i
didn't work with brands like i love
working with friends but it's also the
bread and butter like that's where a
significant amount of
i think most successful youtubers
incomes come from yeah
and if you're not making content um
you lose those opportunities so right
yeah the insanity of it right yeah
that's
part of the matter it makes it hard to
say no so i mean
yeah for us on h3 we still had had a lot
of sponsors lined up
apart from it we just did we had to tell
them all like
no not happening i mean so
i'm in a similar position but i'm trying
to like like literally
line up brand deals that are like if i
can commit to one brand deal a month
dude that's what i tried
i was like i lined up brand deals for
the whole year yeah and i was like
i can't tell you yeah i can't do it well
then i i you know teach there
hearing hearing you under hearing you
and understanding the frustrations
you both have had with your main channel
i don't have those
i don't feel like my contents like i
don't have those sort of struggles i
feel really good about the content that
i'm making and have been making and i
want to make more of it
the problem the obstruction for me is
like
is distraction i mean laziness could be
a way of looking at it but i'm not
exactly what kind of distractions
like you know like i would rather go for
a hike or go surfing or explore this new
place enjoying your actual life yeah i
haven't lived
because you've been in the grind for so
long when you say
enjoying your actual life it sounds it's
indulgent
and i i think it's like it's not
indulgent for me to
let's focus 30 hours a week on making a
video to keep my
lights on and make sure my family has
health insurance yeah but you did that
for
so long and ignored the other everything
yeah yeah
it's such an extreme so no i've swung
the other way and given i've only been
here for two months and in those two
months i have been working
um made a couple of videos but like i
definitely wanted to take this time to
settle and focus on my kids and focus on
honestly like focus on things like this
like being in your podcast the priority
of mine yeah i've been wanting to get
you in there for a while
yeah i haven't said yes to something
like this or being on phil's podcast or
working with other people you know like
i did a
really fun collab with jake roper for
his new original series which was really
fun
like before it was just a blanket no
yeah and like this is so rich like
getting to spend time with people that i
both admire and care about like it's
been i'm talking about jake yeah i i
benefit
you benefit from that that makes you a
better creator it makes you a better
person
yes so that's where my focus is and like
the pressure right now is like
i need to put some structure to my hours
be a little bit more disciplined
and focus so i can find resume a sort of
cadence with
my quote-unquote job um which is also to
be what i love
and also like i get satisfaction out of
it like surfing and running around and
goofing off all day every day is like
is really sexy and cool but i start to
feel bad because it's like i'm not
kidding
it's not that most of the time is with
my kids but i think that's great if i
feel that you're not being productive
right that's right i don't think i'm
doing anything
yeah like there is something that's very
self-fulfilling about
yes even if my job is absolutely absurd
is making youtube videos
i still feel like i'm doing it if we
have like a really rough week and
by rough i mean like really busy a lot
going on
it can be like so hectic but then it
feels so good
at the end of the week because it's like
wow we did so much this week
yeah it's great kind of nice today it's
friday baby yeah
that's going to be one of those weeks
that was like the addiction with
doing that uploading every day for 800
days it was no
joke like this i've never been a drug
guy before yeah
and you're like boom uploaded the second
you click upload especially like yeah
of those 800 days it was like 600 where
i was like 8 a.m
seven days a week was when i'd send it
live and like finishing it and checking
it back and watching it back and seeing
it like go from like
2 40 to 1 10 80 and then like at 7 59
and hitting publish it was like
there it is there's my fix it is it is
when we were
back in uh one of our when we first
moved here in l.a we were doing like two
or three videos a week we were like
crushed like just
a lot for us yeah you're just like oh oh
oh
yeah you're hitting that your main line
but whenever you're mainlining it it
feels so
never we tried that we started to see
our personal life
go down the drain and that personal life
becomes much more consequential when you
have children
yeah i do think that we've struck in a
good balance now i'm happy to say with
the podcast and that
nd teddy fresh we are extremely busy
but it's manageable and uh fulfilling
and i'm able to spend time with my son
and to have
to have some time in the evening to what
to watch the bachelor
for example and uh bachelorette or
bachelor in paradise whatever you
bachelor and paradise stuck
is struck in a word struck in
yeah can you use it a sentence you just
did and that's why i'm bringing it up oh
yeah yes it is you know if you think
people are going to give you a hard time
i think you know your audience might
lose it if your vocabulary is really
nice i know
no he's trying to flex it i'm trying to
fast i've got a uh
compliment okay stricken
struck him straight i think he uses
struck is stricken in the past tense
struck but not struck him
do you really think there's a productive
conversation right now
i will dwell on this in my inner
dialogue for like the next week and a
half
until i get to the bottom of it there's
a statement yeah
for for the for for the folks at home
who are hungry to know
if strucking is a word but no finding
that work-life balance i do think is
like really
that's good and i also do think that
like making the videos in h3 productions
like we made one recently which was the
instagram reality one which i thought
was
was fulfilling and it was fun and it was
great and everybody
just i was very happy with the whole
experience you start a war with like
trisha paytas
yeah she's she she's a lot of fun he has
a lot of fun it was great
um but i do want to
to go there again i think but i'm really
enjoying the
kind of uh
you know i'm on a little different vibe
right now
i'll say back to you what you just said
to me a little while ago which is that
if you can ignore the demands and
requests of an expectations of your
audience and just do what's true to you
you will find success and i'm saying you
but i don't mean you ethan and eli i
just mean in general
and that's the place like i do feel
really happy right now focusing on my
family when i sneak away to my studio
for two hours and i'm editing
that makes me feel even happier so
that's the path i want to continue and
like yeah before i came into your office
sitting in your parking lot
which by the way do you have to pay for
parking
did he give you [ __ ] i didn't bring my
ticket in can you just stamp my hand
we can give you the stickers um i meant
that very lightly by the way as a joke
he's
really serious when i said that um well
we have validation and we'll give it to
you
but i'll say that i mean this is the
business that we run here
was serious when you stick your if i had
to pay the three dollars to park i'd
still come here and be happy during your
podcast
when you started we were validating when
you
you're validating we validate our guests
when you stick your head in the sand
and just ignore all the noise and do
what like really
you find fulfilling right it's so
obvious like it's you can feel it as a
viewer
and that that feels really really good
you know
and i i think that it's very hard to re
remember that
and very trust that and to trust trust
is a better word
to be able to trust yeah it takes a
while to really get there i think we
we've gotten there more recently but it
really i mean we've been doing this now
for like what five six years
everything yeah yeah i guess yeah but i
mean you know
it takes time to learn these things you
have to really
put yourself in the through it all you
have to i
i went on this strucken is an old
english word by the way
what is the definition though what do
you expect i mean it's the past tense
is there go ahead and define it dan gosh
damn yeah it's just the past tense of uh
stricken we can't hear you really
slowing down the show casey i know it's
important to get this right
and then we can gently move on from i
heard that go ahead oh i
guess you couldn't hear me no strucken
is the past tense of stricken yes
and what is tricky it's obsolete so is
that good we'll let it slide
but if it's in we're letting it slide
dana's world but
that means not only is is it a word
indeed but you used it properly
zach why don't you play mega dude why do
you fight me
he goes mega dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm giving a talk at like a a youtuber
get together thinking
next week or i don't know what it is but
it's here in l.a
and it's a big event and i really think
that like the main focus of my
conversation is going to be about
finding long legs as a youtuber or
social media star like what is the long
term
like you guys are you know you guys are
both young like conceivably you work
another 20 or 30 years before you stop
working and all of this success that you
found in your careers has been in the
last five or six
years so is this transferable to a
long-term career
i no one knows the answer to that yeah
no one knows but it's something that
like because i'm 38 and because i
i have three kids i think i consider
that much more
with much more much more reverentially
than like you know jake or logan they're
both early 20s david dobrik he's like
21.
yeah i think it's when you're 21 it's
very hard to be like
what am i going to be doing when i'm 40
or 45 or 50 or 60.
that just seems like a different life it
seems impossible
but when you're on 38 when you're 38
you're like [ __ ]
what am i going to be doing what am i
going to be doing when i'm 45 what am i
going to do when i'm 50.
yeah and that's had an impact on the way
that i conduct myself yeah
that's why it's like really forced me to
take breaks with
the more fun aspects of my career and
focus on the longer term more
serious or opportunistic aspects of my
career which might be good for me and my
family long term
that shit's not fun or sexy
that's why we made teddy fresh you know
we were thinking uh
we gotta we have to create something
that can exist on its own
that we like doing that we
can see us doing long term and
diversification
exactly and i mean that that was the
motivation and
um it's great i love i love it it's
awesome we've
it's great it's been the best thing we
ever did
right right wearing that hat
what wearing that hat exactly like
ela klein see comma i know
all about it that's a good hat it looks
good on you
it looks good on you yeah but like
bifurcating your focus from like
what you do in social media to something
like that is real would you be
willing to discuss the most you ever
made for a brand deal
sure what is it oh like you're gonna
just ask me
[Music]
i'll give numbers i don't like to even i
don't like to because
no but people have no it's fascinating
and if we can
bust a nut bust this nut open rather
i'm trying i'm literally can you can you
stricken the knight
the nut i can struck in the nut let's
try it doesn't make any sense does it
but
i don't think people understand let me
put it this way let me give a little
preface to this conversation and you
don't have to share anything you're not
comfortable with i just okay go
i just you know i know you're a guy that
works with a lot of brands and
i do i think you probably got some big
paychecks yeah
i have no complaints yeah um but i'll
put it this way
when i was first starting out my youtube
career i befriended a big creator
and at the time i was probably making
two or three thousand dollars a month
from ad
had revenue and i thought that's pretty
good
you know and uh he told me i go how much
do you make for uh
for one of those ads because i never
work with the brand in fact we didn't we
didn't go on to work with brands for a
long time
but he goes i make 30 000 for one brand
deal
and i was like what
you know i'm like dude that's how much i
make in a year
and that completely blew my mind i don't
think people understand
necessarily how much money people make
and that
that as someone who had even been doing
youtube for a year or two i was like
30 000 dude that's insane
now i know you're not impressed by that
number are you
no yeah i mean 30 000 30 000
is an ungodly amount of money but it
goes much higher yeah yeah um it goes
much higher
and i think before we start talking
numbers to put a little
context to it to like what is the roi
what's the return on an investment like
that how does that make sense
why would a company write a check for 30
000
to a youtuber you're getting millions of
views i mean it speaks for itself
sure but i think like i look at my wife
candice and i look at what her
ad spending is which you know she's a
tiny startup billy like they're
bootstrapping they don't do
a lot in revenue but the amount of money
that she spends on instagram
on facebook and then just on online ads
and then
there's a very literal quantification of
her return on that investment for every
100 you make you'll make this much back
and then when you start to apply those
same sort of metrics
to a well-executed brand deal which are
the only kinds that i try to do like i
try to do it well so it's really good
for the brand that i'm working with and
it's good for me
um you start to see that makes a lot of
sense when you understand that like
coca-cola spends hundreds of thousands
of dollars for a 30-second commercial
that plays during a basketball game that
literally nobody watches the commercial
because they fast forward you go take a
leak you talk to your friends like you
have a [ __ ] cell phone in your hand
like i do when a commercial comes on
you're not paying attention to that
arby's commercial they're paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
those 30 seconds
what's their return on that and then you
start to compare that to having
ethan and ela talk about that same
product for
90 seconds personally endorse it and why
they endorse
connect with your audience in an
entertaining way that they're actually
engaged and they're listening
like i'm not going to talk numbers so
i'm working with them right now but like
coca-cola
no nordvpn is a company that i work with
and nord's worked with a bunch of
creators
yeah stuff with them they're they're
wonderful but
i'll express it sorry we're going to
blur that whatever without naming names
any vpn company a vpn is a really
difficult thing to communicate
yeah either you know how it works or you
don't and if you don't it's a lot to
explain
and on top that like can you advertise
something like that online it just looks
like it looks strange you don't
understand what it is
so what's a way to communicate the
complexity of that product
and then explain its value and then
hopefully have customers go and buy that
product
you can do that in a [ __ ] tv
commercial no way
you ended up with a banner a banner ad
like where and how are you going to do
that
right so you work with a creator like
that company that i mentioned in
particular has worked with like
phil and they've worked with a bunch of
tech reviewers and all sudden you have a
fairly eloquent
individual who knows how to communicate
ideas to an audience that they
understand they speak with they have a
dialogue with and it's becomes a really
fair value prospect so how much
because that that individual is getting
paid and that company is getting the
exposure they wouldn't otherwise have
access to it right
how much i'm not willing to talk about
that brand but yeah other brands that
i've worked with
um it's difficult for talking about a
single transaction
biggest one ever see i don't have that
i would say like the biggest deal ever
for like to bring up a brand or make a
dedicated video
for a brand is in the six figures like
hundreds of thousands of dollars
as in like more than a hundred thousand
dollars but i'll also say that like in
my career i've had the opportunity to do
things like that a couple of times
right that go that right yeah like when
i talk about like
um samsung like when we did that project
where we turned uh abandoned shopping
mall into a playground for
underprivileged kids
okay my fee on that was not huge and i
donated
i think most of it a significant portion
of it to the boys and girls club of
milwaukee
i just didn't really feel right getting
paid for that um
but like that cost maybe
like seven feet like over a million
dollars just to produce
just to produce and
obviously the brand's intent there was
like we want to be
on our products in front of people and i
shot the whole thing on their phone
but it was not a hard sell for any
individual item
and that's why i was so willing to like
attach my brand to it
i did behind the scenes videos i did
yeah the hero video which did like 5 or
10 million views
i did all of this stuff and it was all
about samsung samsung samsung
because they were like sticking their
necks out to spend over a million
dollars on a project that like
they're not doing print ads they're not
getting like this isn't a super bowl
commercial
this is literally like casey neistat
turning a [ __ ] shopping mall into a
dangerous playground for kids
yeah um so there was a lot of money
thrown at something like that
even though my fee may not have been so
high so that's why i don't have like a
i know it's saturday i paid 200 000 to
talk about this pair of shoes like yeah
that sort of clean transactions never
happened right and on the ones where
there's real money being pushed around
it's usually a far more common it's
more complicated i know it's not as
satisfying as it is no yeah i'm
extremely satisfied
okay yeah i feel good i'm extremely
satisfied the one-off deals that are
like we'll give you 50 grand to say this
yes typically say no to um because
then it starts to feel like your channel
is like this trans this place for
transactions
like i just had a deal and it was very
lucrative it was over it was
six figures but it's from a laptop
company
and what their request was we want you
to do a
product review a video just about our
laptop
and we want you to endorse it oh and for
that we'll give you this much money but
it was like enough money to pay for my
kids [ __ ] college right
it was very hard to say no to yeah but
it did cross the line of
right was acceptable to share with my
audience right and that
that is really really tough because
those opportunities like
yeah we've yeah we get them every day
we've had a lot we've not
a lot not a lot there's been some
opportunities that
some you know it's it's often times that
like
the most lucrative ones are the ones you
really should say
for example i don't want to i don't want
to
disparage anyone a coffee company a cell
phone just
speak in generalities yeah i don't yeah
let's say let's say a company
that that sells uh brain
enhancing drugs or not not drugs
supplement vitamins
okay supplements yeah that i won't touch
and i'm like i'm like
i don't believe in this product right
that's what gets hard i think it's
stupid and just because they're offering
me like six figure deal
i'm gonna look like an idiot if i
promote this and i can't with a straight
face i can't
no i think you guys rightly so we're
super critical of like that
loot box scandal when that came up
was the one the uh that um oh yeah the
ricegum
i got an offer from similar products
similar companies to that like
supplements i get a lot of offers about
i just don't know what it is or what it
means so i have to say no to it
and the flip of that is like that vpn
that i saw that's a product i use right
the irony of that is like i pre-paid
three years in advance before i did a
brand new right so i can't use my code
to get a better deal on a product
i use it i know that it's a good product
yeah when i work with companies that i
actually
and like i like ring for example as a
sponsor like i
love rings yeah and i pursued them and
then when you get a partner like that
it's like you know i believe in it i
think it's a great product they're super
legit then i'm willing to
i've gotten some cool offers and
lucrative offers from car companies
really yeah that i can't that i can't in
good conscience
because you don't like the car i always
make fun of matthew mcconaughey because
he's in all these lincoln commercials
and i'm like that dude does not drive a
lincoln
if if he does he's in the right but like
he does i drive a tesla and i remember
like a car company was pre
was producing an electric car and i was
like
that's cool it's not as good as my te
and i really believe in my tesla and
tesla doesn't pay for advertising
i talk about them all the time but it's
like i couldn't in good conscience be
like
wow this new electric car from this
other company is amazing because i don't
believe that they really aren't
we started looking around like what are
the other options to tesla
and it's not their lead is unreal yeah
the cars yeah it's so much better but
it's good that but anyway that's great
so yeah there's real money but you don't
if you don't do it with a conscience
it's it can really be
well you've got to because okay even if
you're looking at it purely from
i want to make as much money as possible
standpoint it's still short-sighted
because
ultimately it uh
it devalues your your brand to
kind of i will say like one of my
regrets when i was vlogging is that i
didn't figure out the merch thing
sooner yeah that was that was a big
thing i never came out of nowhere though
the paul brothers
the bee the public totally to give them
the credit i think when
when those two guys started selling like
merch everyone was like
holy crap yeah i can tell you for a fact
like you know
those guys and a lot of the guys who
push merch hard they make considerably
more revenue off of their merchandise
sales than they do off their adsense of
course
and i had opportunities early on to do
that when i look back like the loyalty
my audience had for my content when i
was really doing a couple million views
a day
i know the amount of money that i could
have made and the reason why i didn't do
it then and i think i was wrong by the
way
is at the time it felt too predatory
interesting at the time and i don't
believe this now at the time
it felt like to just sell stuff that
people would only be buying because it
was from me
felt inherently dishonest and at the
time
where my head was was like if i'm gonna
do it it has to be
not so dissimilar from the way you're
doing teddy fresh like i need to start
my own line
i'm not just doing merch to do merch i'm
not just making shirts to make shirts
it has to be something bigger and that
it's that thing where it's like
perfection got in the way of good enough
the reality was like i've done some
merch since i've released
i feel like we used to think that too
like a long time ago it didn't help the
way that jake and logan did it then
which was predatory which was super
aggressive
and it was like okay that's the
culmination of everything that i don't
want to be doing in the merge space so
i'm not going to do it
and i think that cost me a lot a lot of
revenue and i also think the thing that
i underestimated is like
when i was like 14 years old the amount
of length the amount of distance the
amount of
effort that i would go through just to
get the right skateboard t-shirt
because i wanted to show the world that
like i'm a super big fan of this
skateboard company
like i do feel like i almost let my
audience know like i should have given
them access to a twenty dollar t-shirt
they're like
awesome yeah and they get to be a part
of the way i didn't respect that though
yeah and that's why i say it's something
that i do regret because it was a
financial loss for me but also like i
think it would have been a cool way
because people walked
yeah i mean dude when we do these meet
and greets people show up with like this
classic merch and it's just like oh
that's
so good it's really funny to see like a
super old shirt
yeah of ours that we probably even
forget that we've ever ever made you
know my merch strategy
stopped and i'm happy to say that i
stopped but my merch strategy was
i made a video like eight years ago that
was like if you want free stickers just
send me a self-addressed stamped
envelope and i'll fill them with
stickers
and we've sent out like tens of
thousands of dollars worth of stickers
which cost pennies to make
and like had to have i had to have
dedicated employees who
only sent out free so my merch strategy
was so bad it cost me yeah
and that was something i wish i had had
my [ __ ] together so i could have done
that in a more effective way
well shop casey neistat dot com i think
i still have some merch up there
go buy something hurry up we got stick
send him a self
uh address do you need to get out of
here i notice your phone blowing up no
no so my phone i shouldn't be saying
this in your [ __ ] podcast my phone
number is on reddit and everywhere else
oh really yeah and i keep it on my phone
permanently one i carry a second phone
nobody has this number
okay yeah but i also keep my phone
permanently in do not disturb mode
so just to see what shows up well note
do not disturb me no calls come
i know but why do you keep why do you
not change the number oh
because i have a 212 cell phone number i
don't know if you know what that means
but 212 is the oldest of old school
new york means manhattan not new york so
you're
it's impossible if you can't get it on a
landline anymore in new york
it took me like three years to get a 212
cell phone number and you're not
supposed to it's like a good parking
spot it's a really good parking spot
and also i know that there'll be a point
in my life where i no longer have
any social media notoriety whatsoever
and the idea and then no one will care
no one will care and i still will you're
in the long run so i'm in the long game
i wonder if you could ever sell that
number
oh you can sell it you can buy them
online oh well how much they cost not
enough to encourage you
but enough where i'm not willing to give
mine up um but in any event no but so my
my phone's not on do not disturb right
now because i'm waiting for a call from
someone
later today that i do whose number i
don't have saved uh so that's why it's
blowing up but i try to respectfully
take it off of your
it's not bothering you slide it under my
thighs
because we've been going for an hour and
a half we've been talking for an hour
and
for a half this always happen yes it is
what do you mean does it always happen
you guys always like suck people into
your time for text i thought we've been
talking for 15 minutes
not always when we have good episodes
though great great because i'm ready
i just thought this is the warm-up
you've only asked me two questions
what dan said two on two numbers range
from
wait 175 to 30 grand yeah
hold on really huge discrepancy
because you're on that site that i know
the marketplace yeah the ones that are
thirty grand are like two one two
six six six six exactly if it's like a
real truck
are you going to spell things out like
two one two no casey
yeah i've done all this homework
dude new yorkers are so psycho they're
the only people in the world willing to
pay thirty thousand dollars
well yeah maybe if no one's bought it
yet that's not the case but i'm gonna go
buy it
at home let me see what else i got here
i'm gonna get a brand deal so i can get
another two one two numbers
oh you see you sold okay you sold beam
for 25 million famously
you yeah i can either confirm or deny
that
oh you can't even but that was the
headline that was that that's
that's a correct statement that was the
headline yeah that was well it was
reported okay
yeah reported is an important act now
now
for after a couple years it seemed to
i guess fizzle out or maybe it didn't
didn't meet
the expectation that they had or there
was some kind or maybe
it didn't meet the expectation that you
had something happened
yeah i mean so it was a very exciting
very exciting opportunity to like grow
something that we
built from zero to something much much
bigger especially under the umbrella of
a gigantic parent company with really
vast reach
but ultimately like my business partner
and i started the company
ultimately we never really found the
footing that we had hoped to find within
such a
bigger parent company and the parent
company's decision was to
bring everything that we had been doing
with them in-house
which they're still doing and they're
still making great content they're still
doing interesting things
they all work out of out of cnn oh they
just they work for cnn now
yeah i mean well this isn't the content
the minute on the
beam youtube channel and other beam
outlets and there's a lot of cross
pollination with some of the content
they're creating
and sort of the more mainstream outlets
of cnn i remember
during the government shutdown last year
there was a really really impactful
piece that was produced entirely by beam
about how it's affected tsa workers and
like that piece was picked up by
anderson cooper
so anderson cooper's reporting is is
reporting on
me reporting on surround where is is
using
a beam report to bolster or to
maybe illustrate some of the things that
he was talking about which to me just
felt like a real
that's sort of the ultimate success so
they're still making incredible work i
couldn't be more proud of what they're
doing
but i think at the end of the day like
my business partner and i
it was not a great match and that's sort
of how that netted out
gave it a shot didn't really work though
i think all around
all around i i don't think that it was
us just giving a shout out to them just
giving it a shot but i think it was a
something we all tried to pursue and
really really good
we had really good interest and we had
really good plans but ultimately
they went in a different it was going to
run a different direction and so
you sold them an app but
well i think that's where a lot of the
the misunderstanding comes from so it
was like
no we weren't just selling them an app
we were selling like
some of the most valuable things that
we'd pulled together at that company is
we had an amazing developer team
that's very hard to do um very very hard
to do especially in new york city
especially when it comes to mobile video
software development like that's a very
hot spot and that's something that every
big company is trying to scoop up even
the facebooks of the world
and all the googles like they would love
and they have such a tremendous appetite
for the kinds of talent that we had
aggregated and brought together on top
of that like we had built a pretty
amazing suite of intellectual property
as well
you know one of the products that beam
launched quietly that was really
successful was
on the election day in 2016 um
a product called exit poll which was
this really cool app
one day only app where like you could
post a video of who you voted for and
why
and then we artificially stacked it so
you'd always see
independent republican democrat
independent republican democrat
so it wasn't about how many people it
was about perspectives
and i remember like an hour into
election day opening up that app
and seeing the passion in the voice of
trump voters
and the sort of hesitation in the voice
of hillary voters and i knew like right
then and there
because of an app that this incredible
team built that
hillary's going to lose the election so
in any event like that was an example of
one of the products that we built so
that acquisition was not for a simple
software product
that acquisition was for sort of the
whole package i see we had a physical
space
we had wild talent we had intellectual
property we had a plan we had an agenda
we had ambition
and you know when we were purchased the
parent company saw an opportunity within
that
so it's a far more holistic thing it was
a more dynamic thing than just simply
buying an app
so when it fell through two years later
was
was there some kind of vesting thing
there or i mean
was that just like a sweet payday and
you guys
i mean so it was it was you know it was
spread
it was sort of different for every
single employee and every i mean i will
say that like
they were amazing in in how it was
structured and how it played out and i
think that
most everybody was part of the team was
very empathetic and understanding about
why this change was taking place
because again it wasn't a shuddering it
was like when
this transition took place to bring it
internal you know i think almost
everybody was offered a very
uh very similar opportunity what they
had working externally internally
then they could choose whether they want
to go work for them or not go work for
them so
uh you know it was it was a difficult
transition but at the end of that
transition i think there's opportunities
there for
for everybody if that makes sense that's
a pretty soft answer to your question
but that's
that's kind of how that how that worked
i see
um like i the way to say it is like they
were
they were really great like cnn was
really
amazing they're believers they were
supportive they're supportive of
everyone
and like the team there was incredible
the people that i was working for there
was incredible awesome
and i like one of the most successful
products we did with beam was about
vaping yeah
yeah yeah and that was with you thank
you guys for doing that
that's a really really interesting
approach on something that had sort of
only been poked fun at
right that's true you know i hope they
make a follow-up about how vaping's
killing everybody
so much for vaping man people are just
dropping dead why is it all sudden
people are just dropping dead from
vaping
people been vaping for a while i don't
know but i my brother-in-law's a doctor
and he and i were discussing this and my
theory that i presented to him
was that like are these people really
getting sick are these like the
equivalent of people who smoke five
packs of cigarettes a day
because i know a lot of people who smoke
cigarettes casually who aren't affected
is the same way as like those people who
are chained smokers
and then i read a thing from one of the
guys who's affected who is a jeweler
if that's a word j-u-l-e-r
he said he was going through three jewel
pods an hour wow
i feel like that's enough to take out a
horse
you know so who knows dan you're i mean
you're a vapor damn what's going on with
dan how much do you vape
you've probably fallen well less now
after all this it seems like um
the people that are dying it's most
likely related to them buying black
market stuff
but there's just not a lot of
information yet i was actually just
reading an article earlier today that um
a news organization i forget who did it
but they did an independent test
of those black market you know
especially the thc ones the weed ones
and like 10 out of 10 of them had
cyanide in it
so so don't buy the black market
why i don't understand like i don't
understand
like these drug the black market drug
producers too who
they just cut a little like uh fentanyl
yeah or whatever and the xanax is like
why yeah i have no idea
what to kill people i don't know if the
whole thing is terrifying
it just makes it cheaper i think that's
an expensive that's like a
good thing i don't know that has to be
the reason there has to be a reason
you can stretch fence at all but like
there's a difference between xanax and
fentanyl i don't even know the
fentanyl is like the strongest opioid on
earth it's an artificial opioid isn't it
i don't know yeah i think so i don't
know but it [ __ ] you up it's powerful
yeah i mean like oh damn we got the you
we got the uh this up this fedex guy
hates my dog
how does somebody hate a cute beautiful
little shredder he just panics and
closes the door
he like ruins it i feel bad but at the
same time it's like
it's just shredder yeah this is a four
pound dog
don't be scared um
yeah i don't know what to think about
all the vaping like what is killing
people about the vaping
i don't know but i i again like when you
see those vape lords that were in your
video
and in my video and meme's video about
that they probably passed now no but
like
those plumes of smoke like i'm not a
vapor but i've definitely tried
jewel before and like when you take a
big puff on it and then exhale there's
like a little bit of
vapor that comes out so how much just
quantitatively
how much are you taking in when you have
one of those things that looks like and
has that the battery pack
really yeah dan you want to come in and
rip it
like dan do you blow a plume when you
exhale yes
okay come blow a sack for us and don't
die on the spot either
like that's insane and do you know
what's killing people like why
how are people just dropping dead from
vaping well like it's
okay first of all let's just see a fat
cloud here show us a fat cloud here just
just blow it like it's gonna have to be
oh god like there's no way that's not
hurting
people i don't even really get it
okay dan if that's a 10. but sometimes
we walk into the office and it looks
like this
that's still a lot it's still alive is
this cotton candy scented
it's uh unicorn cheese that's what we
call it i'm off the unicorn juice now it
smells like yeah
unicorn milk i was like dude that sounds
yeah like it was legit i don't think
a unicorn yeah well i don't know we'll
never know
do you have you have you pulled back on
the vaping since this yeah
no for sure as soon as all this new
because i mean we just don't know yet
like i want to
wait for more information but it's a
good thing to get off of it like we know
exactly
that's not good off of it well i did i
watched a documentary like a bbc
documentary it was like very detailed
where they compared smoking to vaping
and they concluded that by a large
margin vaping was
was much uh less harmful okay than
smoking cigarettes but
which is where i came i was a pack-a-day
smoker for years so
it it helped me get off of that pretty
much instantly as soon as i started
vaping
that was the day i started vaping was
the last day i ever had a cigarette but
i do want to know why are people dying
how are people just vaping and then
dropping dead do you know
well again it seems to be related
they're still investigating what
is happening to them like
physiologically oh well i mean if
there's cyanide in it i mean it's just
it's just lungs collapse yeah their
lungs are just like cyanide it's just
poison right you've got aerated
poisoning yeah it's like a [ __ ] gas
cyanide like
like that doesn't make sense you could
just put like i mean
what could be cheaper than water and
sugar which is essentially what it is
yeah right so
i don't know my friend dan mace he's in
like a zillion of my videos he's south
african
and he was telling me about how the
biggest risk in south africa is like
recreational drugs that young people use
like that makes me sound old when i say
that but like ecstasy or lsd or any of
these
you never know where they come from and
this is [ __ ] african yeah
she said like almost all that shit's cut
with a kind of poison
because the poison does um further the
effect of the drug but it will also kill
you yeah exactly these people are so
wild man you got to keep your clients
alive that's like rule number one right
you got to keep that bring them right to
the yeah bring them right
but when you do that invariably
someone's going to fall over it
and i think vaping's the same way
alfredo doesn't want any part of the
cyanide yeah the vaping man
but yeah happy to say i don't vape i'm
not part of that whole system
i never want to be a part of that system
tell me what's it like to be someone
that
that like enjoys running i am curious
too
we both hate running i know you remember
like one of the first times i ever came
over your house is when you were like
really deep into your
diet and physical you just started
working with the trainer
oh you were eating that didn't last very
long
you know i think what it is for me is
it's like especially as i get older
you don't i don't have any time alone
none literally no time alone now that i
live in l.a
my time in my car which is special
because i have no time alone
and it's a little bit like if you ever
work in a restaurant you know
smokers get to have a smoke break yeah
every day like it's like what the [ __ ]
i just want to have an air brake you
don't have to have an air brake but if
you smoke you get your five minutes an
hour
and running for me is like my smoke
break like i don't think anybody would
understand why i need to disappear for
an hour to a day
every day but when i say i need to go
for a run it makes sense and it does
make me feel good like i'm
i'm not blind to how to what it means to
like
there's almost no version of uh anything
i do in life that makes me out of breath
and that's like feels like a superpower
like it doesn't matter how many flights
of steps i'm running up carrying how
many boxes or bags of groceries
i don't get out of breath yeah that's
pretty great and i value that
that means a lot to me um and like my
heart rate is like that of an elephant
you know what it is yeah my wrestling
heart rate is
last time i checked it it was like 42
beats
a minute wow 45 beats a minute like that
was the ring you want to compare mine's
like 120.
there's no way you should be dead
but that's that's really low very low
that's like an elite athlete low right
and yeah like i value that but the thing
i value more than
anything is like a good book on tape or
a good
podcast and like a two hour run like i'm
moving through space i'm running there's
all this stuff happening around me
my entire physical body's just shut off
it's in cruise control like i can
complete it's an autopilot
it's meditative 100 meditative
and i just lean into it is it always
like that or did you have to uh
work it it's gotten more like when you
started running
yeah was it awful or did you love it no
i liked it but it was challenging i
started running after i like
broke my leg into a zillion pieces when
told i was told i'd never run again so
it was a little bit like um
defiant defiant yeah yeah so i
appreciated that those aspects of it but
physically it sucked
but and then i used to race like i was
on a pro team
um for triathlons for a year maybe two
years
and i used to race competitively and
that was a very different kind of
training like right now i just like to
zone out
but when i was racing competitively it
was really like every every time i go
out
structured at a specific agenda i think
that was actually less enjoyable
but i really liked winning so it became
compulsive
and now it's just about that meditation
now it's just about having a special
time
i have to say the fact that your your
meditative
uh past time is is that it's great
it is it's great right i don't i'm not
like a big drug user like a smoked
potter a little bit now that i'm out in
california it's just everywhere but like
i'm not a drinker i don't like drinking
at all
i don't know it takes me like seven days
to recover from a hangover and i get off
a half a glass of wine
and i can't do it don't drink and then
like drugs beyond that like i'm just not
she's not super attractive but running
is like a real like if i don't get that
fixed i get angry
like when i broke my shoulder my
collarbone rather i had to go like
two weeks almost before i could run
because the up and down just affect the
heel
and i just get angry you ever feel like
overly dependent on it
yeah yeah it's complete like like all
the like all right it's a little bit
annoying that you have to run
i have and i have to i'll give up time
with my kids to go for a run
definitely what's the minimum time you
need to run for
i mean really it's like 45 minutes for
me before it's something
decent like this morning not enough
though the last two days in a row like
yesterday i was in
um joshua tree national park was amazing
i was with a friend of mine and he's a
super fit athlete but he's like a
not a long distance guy and after four
miles he was like
you know he's like i'm going to stop but
you should keep but i went back with
him yeah so that felt like i didn't even
it wasn't even worth going and the same
thing happened this morning i was
meeting a friend
it wasn't even worth it for four miles
not really didn't even get it right
now nothing four miles is enough four
miles does nothing what's a good one for
you like 10
yeah 10 is if um average day is 10. yeah
when i have nothing going on like 10 is
just sort of the norm
um do your kids wonder what's wrong with
you or like why is that a little bit
well like you asked about my older son
like owen was such a champ owen has like
really severe scoliosis he's probably
gonna get backstage
yeah not that it's let him hold him back
he's like a really fit kid yeah
but he raised competitively all through
high school and he would do all my races
with me including half marathons he'd
always show up he'd run everyone the kid
did triathlons and he was like 10.
and i know that like he does not have
the body for it like he literally has a
body that's not for it because of his
scoliosis
that i loved but the girls are maybe a
little young
you loved i love the fact that he was
like
he appreciated it on the level that i
did so much that he would show up and do
it even though he knew he couldn't be
competitive because he was physically
held back
yeah that meant like a lot to me he
wasn't just doing it for me i know he
liked it i thought you were saying you
yeah it sounded like you were saying
you'd love that he had scoliosis no i
know i didn't i hate that he is
i love that he was so committed to like
this thing that i'm also passionate
about that he stuck to it even though
he was struggling man that's gotta be
it's gotta be
so it's just so unusual and i think it's
very
it is very cool too to be 16 years
different from your
from your yeah yeah what is that like
that's just so busy i mean a good
example of it is like when i
am out of town or i have to go to town
for any reason i fly him to new york i
say i fly him that sounds like i'm
i literally text him and i'm like hey
can you be here friday he's like yep
and he just like shows up at our house
in not new york in los angeles just
shows up the house
which means like he figures out how to
get the airport books the ticket
gets on the plane gets off the plane
gets in the uber and makes it all the
way house all by himself he's an adult
this is the kid whose diapers i used
he's like an adult
and then he just he like takes care of
the kids while i'm gone how old is he
now
21. okay so like when i travel
he he like comes steps in and looks
after my kids and the girls adore him
god that's so easy ethan was 21 when we
met
really you guys have been together for
13 years yeah we've yeah i mean we met
it took a while it took a few years or
so actually i understand
[Laughter]
we're going to be married for seven
years in october yeah
but we've been together but anyway but
it just made me think like 21.
21 seems like i moved to new york city
when i was
when i was you know two years younger
than him do you
ever do you feel like the uh parental
role has ever
blurred because you guys are so close
yeah i think it's always been blurred
and i think that when i imagine that
with my girls now it would be chaos
like my daughter francine is just such a
troublemaker if i was like
more her friend than her parent it would
be a disaster but owen's
always been really conservative and
smart and reserved and like
i remember we he started traveling
internationally when it was like four or
five
and he was always in charge of his own
passport wow
that's cute that was very sweet and like
then it was like
understand the implications of losing
this kid yeah that's pretty cool
and he like took such immense pride in
that
and i tried to imagine that with
francine and she'd be like okay no
problem can i have candy and i'd be like
no she's like
[ __ ] you and your passport in the
garbage yeah you know
so with owen it was really like the
credit's all on him but he and i have
always been
friends first wow and i think i
attribute all of his success to like
either his mother or just the fact that
he's in a great human being
but not any sort of genius parental
no like judge me based on how these
goals turned out not him i mean to be
fair today
i mean how good of a parent can you be
at 16 i mean i don't know
how good you were but i can only imagine
i have no idea
yeah i tried my best i was just as
concerned with getting a new dream cast
as i was making sure he knew how to
walk that's so wild damn you knocked up
a girl at 16. that's
badass bro i didn't lose my virginity
until i was like 19.
she was older than me too probably
trouble yeah that was bad how old was
she
kid she's like 19. and you were 16 you
impregnated a 19 year old
oh my gosh
get it get it don't do that kid
yeah work yeah where it happens kids
practice safe sex yeah
you really feel was that the first time
was that did you lose your virginity and
get her pregnant all at once
no but i'm almost positive she was
pregnant from the first time that we
slept together
damn that's the when you're sick
it takes people a while to get pregnant
when you're like 30 30. yeah but when
you're 16 if you like breathe on her go
wrong she gets pregnant
i know i secretly think that candace is
conspiring to
get pregnant again right now secretly
because you're firing
because conspiring yeah because when i i
think it's a vast conspiracy
because you're what i want what are you
no i don't want another kid are you
crazy
and she does here's the thing you have a
house with one baby in it wait what is
she doing what do you what do you
suspect she's doing
it's it's not it's more like she says
things like
i wouldn't have i met with so-and-so and
she's pregnant i couldn't believe it i
couldn't imagine having another kid
she's
she's placing those and i'm like no i
don't want another kid and she's like i
know but just imagine if it were to
happen
i'm like no i will not take that down
yeah i will not imagine
and she's just like or she'll be holding
our baby like
our little baby uh george georgie little
girl she's so
amazing and so it's a cool name by the
way thank you
she's like frannie was never as like
tame and sweet
franny is amazing but she's a
firecracker she's an explosion
and the baby's so good and like we look
at the baby we're like what's the last
time we're we're gonna have babies
and she's wondering this will be like if
it doesn't have to be
you know and it's like she's dropping
those bombs left and right
and i'm terrified terrified of having
another kid
so wait how many people seem so hard
four or five hundred i have three
yeah but it's like when you either use
one or you have infinity amount
that's right i feel like there's a three
three if you have three kids that's like
you're good
that's a lot but that's normal once you
hit four
you might as well have ten it's just
yeah they just don't stop
they just they're just they're just
everywhere all the time i could there's
no way i can imagine
i just feel like i'm getting a grip on
life
there's no way i have a hard time
imagining having another one right now
even though what is it what's the plan
it is the plan yeah we're good
i will say it's not but it seems so hard
i don't know
it feels really unfair to have one kid
like i feel bad like i say they can't
all the time how short-ended of the
stick owen got
mm-hmm no siblings i was all poor when i
grew up with him
yeah he's like dad can i like
my kids now are like dad i can go to
disney world and i'm like no and they're
like please and i'm like okay fine put
on your shoes
right right right and when was only the
kid he was like daddy can i have lunch
and i was like no not today
maybe tomorrow yeah like what do we look
like billionaires no
you ate yesterday um
but no i couldn't another kid right now
just seems all so overwhelming
but yeah that's why i would want more
than one because i
i want you to have you know siblings or
someone to play away i think two or
maybe three well that's what i was
saying i get off track but um
watching the baby look at her older
sister
is for the first time in life like total
clarity of like oh [ __ ] that's what it
was like when i was a kid
you idolize you worship your older
siblings
you're like that is my hero and that's
exactly and i watched the baby just
stare at france
and just like okay i need to model
myself on her and can't it's not like no
no don't do that
don't do that but it's it's fascinating
to watch siblings grow up and i'm glad
we did that but
now i can't do it anymore clears enough
yeah two and done
yeah sign me out okay how much should we
have two or three
i mean have three if you can three more
is always better
four more hmm i mean if you can
handle it my wife just explained to me
this summer that four is a status symbol
really no this is according to the great
people poor
[Laughter]
they can afford it and i'm like no i was
one of four kids
maybe in manhattan or los angeles that
might be true i think she was saying
this when we were on the island of
nantucket
i don't know where nantucket is but i
don't think it's bad there
nantucket is like the island is a status
that's where the men can suck it
nice one nice one knew a man from
nantucket his dick was so long you could
suck it
no i didn't want to knowing that no
thanks for talking about that
somebody somebody knows that no but
there's a lot of
affluent families there that have like a
zillion kids i guess if you have like a
uh
just if you have a yacht that can
accommodate four kids you're young
and it's a status birds and you can have
four kids so she's she wants the status
of having a force no she doesn't want
the status
i just brought it up and i said to her
why does everybody in this island have
four kids in the same suv
and she said it's a status symbol maybe
it is so if you want that
status like if you want that clown you
need to be able to fill you need to be
able to fill an escalade yeah if you
can't fill your escalade up with
children like what's that there's an
empty stomach
then drive off yeah take that out walk
how dare you
okay well we're coming to the end of the
app it's been two hours
um i want to show you a couple videos we
have some new scooter vids should i
watch these scooter vids dan or should i
hold off
um i mean
i don't know i i it seems like a hard
left turn from
conversation okay let's not block this
that's a good return yeah yeah
that's true let me ask you this then
pretty good let's let's end and
the most classic way we possibly can
great um
do you have have you ever seen
experienced
supernatural super natural go have you
ever seen a ghost
have you ever seen the ufo have you ever
been visited have you ever seen a spirit
do you have any supernatural experiences
i mean i watched that bob salazar
documentary if that's what you're
referring to
what did you think about it when you
watched it do you not know about this
documentary yeah
it was [ __ ] tough it could turn out
okay here's the thing
isn't it awful i don't like to throw
people under the bus or be too critical
but
he's one of the most interesting ufo
voices ever this bob salazar guy and
that was one of the worst
made it was like i wanted to hear his
story
but i don't think it's his fault i think
it was not his fault it was not
the first 10 minutes i was like the
first time it's like what are you trying
to talk about and on top of that like
don't conflate the fact that the fbi
keeps raiding his
firework factory with the fact that he's
this like just
just let me listen to this man's speech
that's all i wanted but then the like
material was so massive
the b-roll of like of [ __ ]
aliens like why would you put that in
there it felt like a college project it
was
invalidating what bob salazar was saying
i bounced in 10 minutes because i found
the the production to be so obnoxious
here's the thing the interview that he
did
on the joe rogan podcast though made up
for those
yes that documentary because joe rogan
basically asked all the questions that i
wanted to hear but he's making it all up
right i mean what's your opinion who's
gonna be making it all up what's my
opinion my opinion truly is
i don't know like i would say that nike
said i want to believe him
and i don't know like it's such a
convincing argument and also i'm one of
those people who like wants there to be
aliens you want to
even if the aliens invade planet earth
and kill us all during my lifetime
yo kind of a dope time to be alive you
know what i mean we're all going down
anyway
to believe but we had this guy mick west
who's a uh
scientific debunker and he just
incorporated him yeah
he didn't yeah it was like he's just
kind of repeating some stuff that are
easy to
a lot of right a lot of the stuff he
says are are like have origins and like
old
uh ufo tales of that people used to say
back in like the 50s from abduction
experience and stuff and
and ufo circles he says like oh it's
from this specific star system
that originates back so he thinks he's
just sort of the heavy
heavy the heavy uh particle that he says
they used as fuel
he says that that was something we were
inevitably going to discover
anyway as part of like like they knew
that that was going to be next
to be discovered or something like that
and like
that particle there's just there's no
explanation
really for i don't know well that's fine
i just want to believe him but it's cool
it sounds like a cool story yeah it's
that's what i like is so romantic and
just awesome and fun but no i've never
had a first hand okay you have it alien
experience but
i'm waiting and i'm psyched for my first
one
nothing i'm not much of a believer in
that me neither
people like me to ask that which is
annoying i don't believe
i was hired to film a series for like
discovering one of those channels
it was like the unknown or something and
i think i filmed two episodes where
before they fired me and had to redo the
whole show because my production company
lost the entire contract
and part of the reason why is because i
thought everything we were seeing was
[ __ ]
the first pilot he shot was about this
kid who can
speak to who was like reincarnated and
could identify all the minutia
of his previous life where he used to
live on the street
so we went to like get into it and it
was just all felt like all [ __ ]
he was like i used to be a movie star
who's alive in the 50s and it's like
cool
cool thing to say kid and then so we
like brought him from texas to hollywood
and he was like i remember this street
if i could see the street and we're like
find the street and like
this and it's like it was just all it's
just stupid
you had to be one of those people who
really like goes so far out there to
believe
yeah that you're willing to ignore
everything yeah
that you're willing to ignore all the
truths because they don't fit in with
your
version of reality you watch the flat
earth documentary on netflix
no it's awesome really okay i'd watch
that it's so good
flat earth is like my favorite things
it's about these guys who
are like super flat earth and they start
doing they're trying to prove that the
earth is flat and so they're getting
really high tech stuff and actually
really scientific approach
and the more rigorous their experiments
the the more they keep disproving
themselves
but it's interesting that uh they keep
finding ways
to invalidate their experiments for
example this guy bought like a 30 000
gyro to to measure the earth's rotation
and he they haven't mic'd up with a lav
at one point and he's telling people
he's like well to be honest the gyro
experiments
they didn't go well at all like if
anyone found this experiment if i
release these
right now as they are we would be in
trouble flat earth will be in trouble
right and then at the very end they set
up this really elaborate experiment with
lasers out in like
the flatbeds uh desert and they set up
these um
like a mile apart like these uh
some kind of cardboard with us cut out
and they're like well
if if the earth is flat like we say
it's going to go through all of them
equally but if it's curved because
there's so much space between them
you you won't see it going through right
like it'll
be like a laser so anyway they they do
it really scientifically they do
the math correct and everything and sure
enough there's no
it proves once again that the earth is
curved see the reason why they're like
they're like the reason why that
conspiracy is so great to me is like
there's really no benefit in proving out
their ridiculous theory like the the
suggestion that there's a global
conspiracy for the earth to be around is
like the end game right their conspiracy
nobody wins from that it's just so funny
nasa can like
make a couple bucks like that's just so
nasa doesn't make money they just spend
it i feel like they just find like a
group that they can be a part of
that's the problem i'm being honest just
run with it
without the internet [ __ ] like flat
earth would never speaking of bridge
we're talking about flat ass we just end
this podcast right now
yeah okay okay thank you guys thanks
podcast
flatcast no we should end it um it's
been two hours over two hours
yeah so guys what's today friday
friday what do we have we have bobby lee
on tuesday that's right that's right
bobby lee and
uh and that's it how many days oh and
kalai layumin
twice a week friday tuesday and friday
uh so bobby lee and kalila will be
joining us on tuesday that's really
exciting
um friday we're going to be doing the
regola shermegala
teddyfresh.com get that new collection
do you have any what are you plugging i
got nothing to plug
just happened to
are you going to consider getting a
scooter yeah right around her in a rush
to get out of here
i'm going to go pick my own up okay okay
that's what i'm saying i was wondering
if you had to get out of here yeah no i
just i'm just gonna stay in the hallway
and buy it on my cell phone but
yeah okay i'm excited about it yeah okay
well we gotta take care of that so guys
thank you for watching have a fantastic
weekend
a blessed weekend a god blessed weekend
don't use the r word like me i feel like
i need a little grace period on the
other word like they revoke that too
quick
yeah i feel like you okay as long as
you're i'm
phasing out i acknowledge as long as
you're acknowledging my knowledge
okay then i i give you a pass okay thank
you
that's the official right i need a
little grey spirit on the r word you
guys
now i'm american so i have a say yeah by
the way congrats
thank you thank you i really appreciate
it me
i don't you just give her through our
muzzle yeah because i am totally
married to a jew with jewish kids we
celebrate shabbat
oh okay wait are you serious i can't
tell if you're kidding i had a coupon at
my wedding
and got like ridiculed for wearing a
[ __ ] keeper by who
like when i posted a picture on
instagram so you're not getting got
married totally serious people were
hating on you yeah
yeah like what's on his head
that's the best question underneath
god bless big dinner big sunday night
every sunday night's the big night
sunday yeah you guys are doing it wrong
it's supposed to be friday night
sunday no what's sunday night sunday
it's the end of bro sunday's the
beginning oh the end of the weekend no
there's a
holiday this weekend oh this is rosh
hashanah starts sunday night right
yeah i don't even know see now i'm
sitting here schooling you
two terrible
but we use every friday it's an excuse
to get together and we call it shabbat
and we do light the candles and say the
prayers you do can we say a prayer
together that's pretty crazy
do you know like the hanukkah prayer
like my mom does and i don't
know
no i'm american that's my new identity
better it hits me than this
can we invite ourselves
where's the music zach you didn't even
play one
sound bite today and you can't hit me
with the taba aguila
are we done okay good
thank you guys see you all thank you all
bye
[Music]
you